Hello, everybody!
Hello, hello!
Welcome to the Dell and Dawson Stationery and Supplies Collab.
For those who don't know what this game is about...
By the way, I had a really good lunch and I'm sort of tired right now.
I'm just like, no!
Why did I have to eat something good today?
Now I'm tired!
Why does my body betray me like this?
Anyway, so as I was saying...
As I was saying, for those who don't know what this game is about...
It's basically The Office, but what if it's Among Us?
Like, it's literally The Office.
So there's like a map on there where it's a one-to-one recreation of The Office's office.
And they even have like one of the tasks you have to do.
Like, if you're like the imposter, which is like the slacker...
You have to put a jello on a stapler.
So it's literally...
They literally just took The Office and was like, Among Us.
By the way, I've never worked an office job before.
So like, my only knowledge of what an office job is gonna be like is literally The Office.
So like, I don't know.
I think this is a heavy roleplay lobby.
So I'm just like, I've never worked in an office before.
What do I...
Paperwork.
I was like, paperwork?
Doing inventory?
The quarterly reports?
Sensitivity trading?
Like, I'm just gonna spout out random office lingo and see if like...
See if it works.
Okay, so...
I was invited by...
Shoto to join the collab.
It's with a lot of Fleshtubers.
I believe majority of them is from...
Offline TV.
So...
I was given a list of people in the collab.
But they said there's more people.
So like, I don't really know who the...
Like, what's the full list?
I don't...
I don't know who are the full list of participants.
But...
It's a lot of Fleshtubers.
I think it's just me and Shoto are the only VTubers participating, I believe.
Unless IKUNA...
Shoto is going in in his VTuber form.
But it's me, Shoto, Sykuno, LM, Valkyrie, Tina, Kitten, FoolishGamers, ChocoBars, Katamina, Maisayoshi, plus more.
This was like the list I got.
So yeah.
It's gonna be very interesting.
I have played this game before.
They invited me before.
Almost the same group.
But I didn't stream my POV.
So today...
I am going to stream my POV.
Just cause I was like...
Fuck it.
You know?
Like...
I didn't stream a lot of my POVs during the other collabs I was invited with the Fleshtubers.
But today I feel like you guys don't need to play Worst Jokey Bird and try to find me in like 200 POVs.
Today I'll actually be there.
Like...
I'll actually be there.
Yeah.
Like I said...
I think this is a heavy roleplay.
This is gonna be a heavy office roleplay.
I don't know.
I'm not sure.
It really depends.
It's gonna be very difficult to figure out who this...
I don't wanna be the manager.
I feel like that's too much stress already.
Like I'm already CEO.
Like I'm already IRL director of my own company.
I don't...
I don't need to...
I'm here...
I'm here to get away from that.
Like...
I wanna be an employee.
I don't...
I don't wanna be the manager.
I don't wanna live my life right now.
I don't need a roleplay.
I'm trying to run away from my problems here.
Not relive it.
Guys...
We're here to escape reality here.
That's what video games is for.
Dr. Cranberry.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Doki is the slacker of her own company.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I don't think the lobby is ready yet because like I'm looking at the Discord server and nobody's in it.
I don't know.
Maybe like it's another server that I'm not aware of because that would be very awkward if it is.
I hope it's not so...
I hope it's not another server that I wasn't aware of.
Like...
I'm gonna double check.
Okay.
No.
Sykuna's playing Street Fighter.
Okay.
That's good.
Um...
And I think like Chodo's watching a YouTube video.
Okay.
So that's good.
I'm not late.
Yeah.
Okay.
Good.
We're not late.
No.
No one...
It can't be.
No.
I'm not in the wrong server.
There's nobody on the server.
There's no way.
Did I get the right time?
Yes.
I did.
They said 2 p.m.
Okay.
Oh my god.
Is it 2.30 p.m.?
Did I get the time wrong?
I need a double...
Don't do this to me, guys.
Now I'm second.
This is why I can't be the manager right now.
I'm...
No.
It is.
Okay.
You guys...
It is at 2 p.m.
PST.
It can't be any other time zone because PST is the latest out of all the NA time zone.
Unless you live in Alaska.
But like...
It can't be EST because if it's EST, I'm gonna die.
The collab would have already happened, chat.
If it was CST, the collab would have already happened.
So it has to be PST.
Oh, sorry.
I saw somebody said it was their birthday but they couldn't be here.
So we gotta wish them a happy birthday.
Hey.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Hi, future Doki.
I won't be able to watch today's stream because of work but was hoping I would get a happy birthday.
Can't wait to watch the VOD later and laugh at your hijinks didn't true.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Happy birthday to you.
If you're watching the VOD now, happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday, dear Haze.
Happy birthday to you.
Yeah!
It's the mandatory birthday celebration at the office.
Yeah.
Can everybody sign a card for Haze and I'll chip in like $1.
We all chip in for $1.
We can buy him a cake.
I also know about that.
But yeah.
I'm really nervous.
I always get nervous.
I get super nervous in a big group of people.
And like a lot of them are like really, really big streamers too.
So yeah.
I'm like super, I'm super duper nervous in general.
Like I'm okay.
Like during like...
Thank you all for chipping in.
Thank you Normal and Ruji for chipping into the birthday cake for Haze's birthday cake.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
So I'm super nervous.
Guys, some of them have been in movies, guys.
Some of them have been in movies, guys.
I'm just...
I'm just a VTuber.
So I am like off-stream...
Like when I'm not doing these...
When I'm doing these collabs off-stream, it's less nerve-wracking because like you guys don't get...
You guys don't watch me fuck.
You guys don't watch me fumble.
Like spill my spaghetti all over the place.
And like there's less eyes on me when it's happening.
But now that I'm also streaming, I'm like...
It's okay.
It's my first 9 to 5...
Okay.
No, it's not my first 9 to 5 job.
But it's my first 9 to 5 office job.
So like we all get one.
We all get one...
You know what?
We all get one chance to fuck up working at an office.
So it'll be okay.
Like we're selling paper.
Like how hard can it be?
We're literally selling paper.
Let's see.
Troll, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Nothing but love for the punctual like a CEO and trolling queen deal-keeper.
This would be awesome.
Keep calm.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I really appreciate them inviting me though.
I was very surprised that they...
sent me an invite.
Because I'm like, me?
Am I funny enough?
Me?
So yeah.
I really do appreciate that they invited me to join this collab.
Oh yeah.
Can't be any worse than yesterday.
Die via buzz sauce.
Hey.
It molded us.
Okay.
Like we went straight to level 15.
And we got past level 15.
Okay.
We did stage one of level 15.
We can do anything now.
Most likely part two of that collab, by the way, will be on the week of October.
Because a lot of the other girls will be busy next week.
So we decided to make it on the first week of October.
So it won't be next week.
By the way, most likely next week will be like mostly solo streams.
Because I had two big like collab streams.
I had two big collab streams this week.
So like I'm gonna recharge my battery.
Unless like...
Unless LM invited me to a collab.
Then maybe...
Look guys.
I'm trying to make friends.
Okay.
I'm trying my best.
It's time for me to make new friends.
Just...
I'm just trying to make new friends and expand my network guys.
I'm always super nervous about it.
Because I'm like...
I'm like...
I don't know what I'm doing.
Okay.
I'm gonna double check.
If people are in the void.
No, people are not in...
What do people do when they...
Is...
I...
I'm so not used to like starting a collab stream.
And just being alone.
At the beginning.
I'm not used to that.
I'm just like...
What do I...
Do I just talk until...
What do I do?
Just...
There...
And then I call?
Are you...
Wait.
Are you serious?
Okay.
I...
What?
What server are they on?
Wait.
What?
I...
I'm late?
I'm actually late.
Oh.
There's no way.
There's no way I'm fucking...
Oh my god.
Okay.
I might be...
I might be late guys.
I might...
I might be...
What server are they on?
What?
What the fuck?
I was late?
Two, four...
No.
I'm not.
I'm not late.
There's people missing.
Literally, there's people...
Literally.
Jodo's not even in here.
And he's the one that organized this collab.
I'm not late.
I'm...
Jodo organized this collab.
I'm not...
He's not even here.
Oh my god.
Okay.
That's good.
Let's...
Oh.
I can't show the screen because, like, it has the code, guys.
I can't show...
Wait.
How do I...
This...
How do I not show the code?
Oh no.
How do I block the...
Oh.
This is why...
This is why I don't stream these two.
Oh.
I'm already up just in case.
Oh my god.
Oh my...
I can't believe I was late.
I was so...
I was confused.
Fast log.
Thank you for the 50.
Give the chips.
Thank you.
There's another server?
Okay.
That'll be...
I'll message...
I'll message Jodo.
It'll be late.
What the...
Screen server.
Are you guys in...
Oh.
Streamer mode.
There's a streamer mode.
I thought...
I thought it was...
I didn't realize.
There was more than one.
I'm new here.
I...
Okay.
Can I like...
Leave?
I can't leave?
How do I...
Oh.
Okay.
There we go.
Settings.
I'm going to put streamer mode just in case.
Okay.
Oh.
No.
I reset everything.
Okay.
No.
Did I reset everything?
I accidentally reset everything.
Oh.
Okay.
Push to talk.
Device.
Microphone device.
Okay.
Guys.
It's...
It's fine.
Everything is fine.
Everything is okay.
Okay.
I think...
I think I'm in the...
What is device one, two, three?
Oh.
I don't know.
I hope device two is the right device.
I don't...
I literally don't know.
Okay.
Let me see if it works.
Oh.
It's hidden.
Nice.
Okay.
It's hidden now.
All right.
We're fine.
Everything is fine.
I mess...
At message.
What's the Discord server we're on?
And nobody said...
And like...
I haven't got a response yet.
So we'll see.
Okay.
Doki.
It's Thursday.
The cloud was yesterday.
Yesterday.
You missed it.
Farina.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Okay.
It's fine.
We're...
We're fine.
We...
I don't know what server we're in.
But...
What server everybody else is in.
But like...
That's fine.
I'll just talk in the office.
All right.
Hey.
I'll just...
I'll just talk...
I'll just talk in the game.
I'll just...
Hey.
It's okay.
Yeah.
There's proximity voice chat, anyway.
It's okay.
We're missing...
We're missing like.
We're missing people.
Yeah.
We are.
This can't be all of them.
We're missing...
Yeah.
We're missing people.
Um...
We can't write a message.
Okay.
I'll just...
No.
I don't want to be like hey.
What's up.
That's good.
Because then people be like.
Oh.
Oh, she's the new hire.
What if they hate me?
I don't want to be... they're like, oh, fresh me.
I don't want to say like, hey guys, what servers are we?
Nobody told me... I don't see anybody in the server that's usually...
as with the collabs.
Oh, I got an invite.
Let's go.
It's called... oh my god, it's the friend server.
Oh my god, I'm in.
I'm spilling my spaghetti already.
I told you guys, when I'm on the stream, it's worse for me.
Okay, I need...
I'm gonna do push to mute.
I can't.
I can't, guys.
Okay, what's the... what is my key button for mute?
I don't... I don't usually do mute, so I don't know.
Okay.
Okay, this is fine.
All right.
Push to talk.
I haven't joined yet, because I'm like, nervous.
Devastated.
Oh, you're gonna get the wood cream back out.
No, no, no.
Well, actually, the wood cream does protect it from messes like these, you know.
And you cause a lot of those.
I do.
Well, actually, what started it all was last night.
I accidentally filled...
Guys, I... I pushed the top, so I'm trying to get the overlay...
Overlay, correct.
...button tower, whatever.
I don't know what it's called.
But...
You need a bib!
What is it?
Because this happens too often.
Guys, Lily is coming.
Yay!
Hi, Lily.
Nice!
Where's the friends?
Oh, my God.
Another one.
Janet, you're here.
You made it.
I'm here, and I'm not technically late is what I'm hearing, because somebody else is joining after me.
Woo!
That's what I like to say.
You're funny.
No, no.
I think you're still late, but I mean, you should have just said let's pin the blame on, you know, the people that aren't here.
Oh, boy.
There you go.
Sorry, I was trying to figure it out.
I'm so nervous.
That's why you're a goddamn genius.
For what?
Thank you.
And for my first act, I'm banning Ellum from everyone's chat.
Are you ready to ban from everyone's chats?
I haven't seen him type in my chat in a hot minute.
I can't lie.
I feel like he might be banned.
Wait, what?
Why is he banned?
Slash unbanned Ellum.
No.
Oh, God.
Wait, Janet's in this lobby?
Yeah.
Oh.
Wait, Janet's late.
That's like a weird...
He's not banned in my channel.
I'm gonna ban him.
Hi, Janet.
What did...
Hi, Shoto.
Oh, my God.
Where did he go?
He's not even here to defend himself.
Wait, what did Ellum even do to get banned?
Oh.
Oh, my God.
Where did we fucking start?
Where did we start?
Honestly.
What did...
He nods.
He was the best.
Oh, could I...
He nodded to the lobby.
Oh.
Maybe I can invite?
Or I don't know.
Oh, my God.
I'm so nervous.
Can you guys hear me?
Oh, yes.
Hello.
Why are you here?
Are you...
Oh.
Wait.
What do you mean shock?
Well, see.
Dakken was a hot commodity last time we played this.
I caught him.
I'm sitting on the toilet.
Okay.
Oh.
What?
Listen.
Chat highly requested Dakken.
He does that.
You watch out for him.
He's wishy-washy, man.
Oh.
Dakken.
Okay.
That is great.
Listen.
I'm reformed.
Come on.
Reformed.
No.
That's not right.
Yeah.
I'm standing on Benins.
You're toxic?
I'm toxic?
He's toxic.
He's toxic as heck.
I'm not joking around.
I'm just...
He did not joke around.
You're just being... fuckboy.
Oh.
What?
Yes.
Exactly.
Thank you.
You're just kicking them right now.
I can just kick them.
We don't have to play with them.
I joined for 10 seconds and I get attacked already.
What is going on?
Doki.
Hello.
Hello, everybody.
Doki.
Hello, Doki.
Oh, did you say Lily or Shy Lilly?
Lily or Shy Lilly?
I'm Shai.
I'm so shy.
Why do you know that she's on a plane specifically?
She's on a plane.
She's crazy.
Shoto Docs that she's on a plane.
That's crazy.
It's all my God.
Everybody, meet and greet at the airport.
A day ago or something.
Oh my god.
Perfectly, right?
Like, when she's gonna land...
Yo, just say the flight number, Shoto.
Like, seriously.
Yeah, yeah, just give us the flight number, destination.
Stupid as ever.
Springfield!
Alright, I'll bring Shoto up.
Yeah, we're going back to my home route.
What are the odds?
Well, not exactly Springfield, but Ohio!
Um, okay, Daka needs to ready.
Ray needs to ready.
Or can I just ready ourselves?
Oh, we all ready.
Is everyone in this call here?
Everyone in the... Oh, it is in-game voice, by the way.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, so we mute ourselves here.
Oh, yeah, Shoto, I forgot you haven't played.
You guys should have played the tutorial.
Tutorial Pistorio.
There's just one thing you guys have to know for the newbies.
Um, so...
So, even if you are the neutral type, you still have to do the bad quest in order to do the good quest.
So, I know it's like, you're gonna try to want to avoid the slacker quest, but you have to do it to do the next ones.
That's all you need to know.
So, I do all my quests.
Okay.
Yeah, yeah, you have to do all of it.
Sorry.
Oh!
Wow, just on time!
We made it.
Hello.
Oh, my God.
How Street Fighter?
Bro, I'm gonna watch you compete.
I'm gonna watch you.
Shit.
Bro, I'm like not eating properly.
Oh, no!
I respect the grind.
I just messaged her that.
Oh, thank you.
I heard her.
She's in the game.
Fears the Fathom, Episode 5.
Bro, you killed me twice, by the way.
I hate that.
Oh, Lily's here.
Fucking Nora.
Dude, Nora.
Yeah.
God damn it, Nora.
Oh, God.
Okay.
I'm gonna take a break from Street Fighter and play this nice little Dawn and Dawson game.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I recommend it to Ray.
I think Ray was the only one that did the tutorial.
Out of all of us.
Yeah.
There's a lot of new people here today.
That's so fair.
It's gonna be fun.
Alright, I'm ready for the...
Wait.
Gianna, you banned me?
Oh, my God.
There's so many.
Why is there so many people in this call?
Someone invite Lily.
He does deserve it.
Oh, my God.
It's a whole line.
It's a conga line.
It don't even fit on my screen anymore.
It's toxic.
Oh, my God.
I would never tell you.
The sky is...
It's a conga line.
Why are you making it like that?
He's literally...
What the fuck?
It's a high score line.
I'm like the exchange student.
Yes.
But where...
I thought Sakuna was coming.
Where is he?
He's in the game.
Oh, he's in...
Okay, okay.
Alright.
Ready up, Tina.
You sending me a pigeon...
A gif of a pigeon jumping.
Oh, my God.
This is crazy.
That is crazy.
So he's in the camera.
Oh, my God.
I just like the actual, you know.
Like send it to me when it's awkward as well.
Oh, my God.
And then he said, actually, though.
Oh, you're ready up, Tina.
Oh, me?
Oh, sorry.
Oh, yeah.
Okay.
Me, myself here.
Yeah.
Well, yeah.
It's in-game voice.
In-game voice.
Oh, really?
Yeah, yeah.
You are...
Oh, ho, ho.
I made my life...
Oh, my God.
Okay.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I can be social.
I can interact with other people.
Oh, my God.
I can just laugh.
Whoa.
Somebody's echoing.
Oh, no.
It's probably Shoto.
Shoto's always echoing.
It's Shoto.
It's 100% Shoto.
You bastard.
Oh, foolish.
I'm going to laugh.
No.
I didn't mean to do that.
I don't know.
I don't think it's me.
I didn't mean to.
I pressed the wrong button.
Oh, yeah.
I didn't mean to.
Oh.
He's just faking me.
Wait.
I'm new here.
I got...
What's our work?
Wait.
I'm not echoing.
I'm fine.
Is it me?
Is it...
I don't know if device too.
Is that...
What is my device?
Okay.
Wait.
Who's echoing?
Is it me?
Am I echoing?
Oh.
Did someone unlock this door?
Can you please open the door, Mr. Manager?
Oh.
Here we go.
I unlocked it.
Oh, nice.
Okay.
Where's my desk?
Where is it?
Does anyone know where my desk is?
Oh.
Hello.
Nice to meet you.
I just got hired.
Oh.
Good to...
Hello.
Good to meet you, too.
Yeah.
Oh.
Wait.
I forgot...
Whoa.
Is that...
Is that office practices here?
Oh.
Okay.
There we go.
Yeah.
We need a meeting.
I realized I was the one that was echoing.
Okay.
Oh.
Nice.
Okay.
I got it.
Oh.
Wow.
All right.
I'm going to turn up the game.
Yeah.
There we go.
Who gets locked in the door?
Okay.
Is that better, guys?
No.
Okay.
I know it's chaotic right now, but I think HR's...
I'm sorry.
I also...
All right.
Is it better now?
I just wanted to talk big to intimidate you and...
Dude.
That's my only...
Okay.
Listen.
I'll be honest.
Someone's going to need to get fired.
Okay?
Wait.
But we have a minute left.
Yeah.
We got to figure this out or else I get fired and I don't want to do that.
I love my job.
I think you're a good manager.
I think he sucks.
Wait.
What?
It was...
Oh.
Okay.
You're so good at this.
Dude.
That was dessert.
Oh, my gosh.
Guys, cheese.
You're a jerk.
I told you how...
Oh!
Oh, Elem was the slacker.
All right.
You'll do great in your new janitor position.
Dude, Elem, you're so bad.
Hi.
We already discovered us a slacker, Elem.
All right, guys.
Jump shop, okay?
I don't pay you by the hour.
Get back to work.
I'm ready.
No, please.
What do I have to do?
I have to use my computer.
Where the fuck is my computer?
Okay.
Computer?
Alright.
Guys, we're gonna learn how to work in an office.
Okay, I gotta order a mouse.
Okay, uh... Inventory.
Mouse.
Paper.
Papering.
Okay.
Nice, I did it!
We need to do as many tasks, specialist tasks, to outdo the slacker tasks.
I'm getting them all done, don't even worry about it!
I need to shake hands with somebody.
I'm here.
Who do I shake hands with?
Oh, Tina, hello!
My name is Doki.
It's very nice to meet you, I gotta shake your hand.
Hi, Doki!
Can I shake your hand, please?
No, I'm sorry!
Oh, thank you.
Sorry, sorry, I lived inside for 20 years.
So, my social interaction is not great.
Does anyone know where Blau's office is?
Where's the paper?
Oh, my God.
Okay, there you go.
Guys, I don't know how to interact socially anymore, guys.
I don't know how to interact with people anymore.
I was a very sheltered child.
A very sheltered child.
Okay, I did my new task.
Okay, you know what?
I deserve something.
Oh, where's the kitchen?
Where's the kitchen?
Why is this office so big?
Oh, thank God.
Okay.
Wait, how does... why does that make sense?
Alright, you guys wanna... does anyone drink with me?
You're catching the slackers.
Guys, today was a hard day of work.
Yeah, I played Street Fighter for 10 hours.
Yeah, you need a drink.
It's alright.
It's only 2 p.m.
We all need a drink here.
Did I stutter?
Yeah.
Like, who no drink with us?
I feel like it's only 2 p.m., right?
I can't wait till Saturday's over.
It's just pre-drinking.
At worst, you get second place.
I know, but no one...
Hey, who remembers second place?
You do.
You will always remember second place for the rest of your life.
Yeah, cause she's gonna be in second place.
Yeah!
You're winning, right?
Don't you?
Yeah, exactly!
Am I right?
Wait, what?
Wait, guys, the meeting!
The meeting!
Oh, cause we're drunk on work.
Oh, the meeting, guys!
We have to go to the meeting!
I mean, I'm glad you don't say anything, right?
Maybe we don't have to care about that.
I need to speak to the manager.
That's true.
We don't...
What are you gonna do?
Fire us if we don't show up?
There's so many of us.
They can't keep count.
I made it.
Everyone's lost.
It's a new place.
Thank you.
Yeah, this looks good.
You have really cool glasses.
I trust you.
You're a slacker.
I'm sitting down.
Oh, you're asking me who the slacker is?
Who said I was sitting?
Thank you, sorry!
I was late!
My bad.
That's a lie.
You guys are so late to the meeting.
Alright.
Well, then, I guess I have no choice.
I guess I have no choice.
Oh!
He was the person.
Good job.
Good job, manager.
Very good.
Wait, what do I do?
Report relay.
Use my computer again?
Alright, let's see.
Print the sales report.
Use my computer.
No, no connection!
How am I supposed to do my job and pay for my family?
What are you yelling for?
There's no connection to the server, Tina!
Oh, okay.
Oh, there you go.
Oh, yes!
Yay!
Complaining works!
Inventory.
Pick up sales confirmation.
Print the sales confirmation.
Okay.
Alright, I'm printing.
Is this what?
Is this real?
Is this what you have to go through every day?
Chat?
The super chat me?
I'm so sorry.
Okay.
I need to pick up the sales confirmation.
Oh, financials!
Okay, I can organize this right now.
Grab.
Oh, this is the sales confirmation!
Wait!
That's from a book!
I printed it!
It's out!
This is...
Well, well, well.
Hello, Ellen.
Look who it is.
Look who got demoted and fired.
Oh, the cigarettes.
So you're saying I'm beneath you right now is what you're trying to say?
I mean, in the hierarchy, yeah.
Woah!
That's right.
Oh, you weren't meant to...
Woah!
Wait!
Hey, suck it up.
Someone clearly didn't go to sensitivity training.
Take a little puff, man.
Take a little puff.
Okay, I need Foolish to write this.
Where's the boss?
Yeah, no, there's not too much.
Excuse me.
Oh, where's...
There's not too much for you in the game.
You can't just do your tasks and think about winning.
Okay.
Uh, manager?
I need you to sign this quarterly report.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay, you're done for, pal.
This is your last day.
I'm being harassed!
Why are you smoking inside that's been banned for years?
Oh, thank you.
Thank you, sir.
Oh, here's a slap for good luck.
I'm being harassed.
Okay.
Everything is about to start.
Where's... where's the bulletin board?
No, please!
I just got the report!
It cleansed... it bled my report!
These are all believable things.
No!
Neon's innocent.
Is she innocent?
I helped her do her tasks.
I was doing my tasks and she kept asking me about the... about my kids.
I wasn't slacking.
I was literally... I literally saw in your emails that they were asking for 20 extra boxes of paper.
You're gonna have to do the hard job no one wants to do.
Which I bet you wouldn't know because you're just slacking.
I was in this damn room all the time.
I found Neon smoking.
Neon smoking.
We can't... we can't refire him.
He's already fired fired.
Please get out of here.
Does anyone have any leads on the slacker or am I simply gonna have to go with my gun?
I thought everyone said it was Tina.
I'm good.
No!
Wait, why would it be Tina?
She just got hired.
I'm like the second in smoke.
Okay.
Yeah, wait.
Can we deal with that, guys?
Are we just gonna sit...
We should just kick the janitor out.
He's not even employee.
Why did you fire him again?
We fired him again?
You can fire him again?
He fired the janitor again?
That's crazy.
That is so crazy.
Okay.
No!
This support doesn't work.
Yeah, I can't wait for you.
Give me a second.
I need to drop by and report.
Thank you so much.
Okay.
This is a fire.
Oh, I'm so sorry.
It's okay.
Is that how hand shakes work?
Yeah.
All right, here.
Here's a smack for good luck to you.
Oh, yeah.
No, that's in my country.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
What country is it?
Which country?
It's just like...
In the country of Blau, you smack your ass for high.
Okay.
Use a computer.
I didn't pick up another self-cover.
Where?
I don't want...
Oh, there it is.
Okay.
Grab cells.
Hey, hey.
I'm grabbing my other quarterly report.
We have so many good quarterlies.
Wow.
Perfect.
Yeah, yeah.
Business is booming.
Our stock is rising.
Did you know that?
Don't let them know.
I bought some of our stock too.
I think that's legal, right?
Okay.
You know what?
In Ohio, anything's legal.
Oh, nice.
All right.
You hear that guy?
There's no signal.
Okay.
There's no such thing as...
Our boss said there's no such thing as insider trading.
Okay.
Make a copy.
We're...
Oh, there.
Okay.
Here we go.
Good old Ohio.
All right.
Put the sales report on...
Okay.
There.
Ow.
Something like on your computer instead.
Oh, you can play Snake.
Yeah.
Like, what are you doing?
Because I feel like you're not all there.
Okay.
Let's see.
The paper tray.
Wait.
I can't pick it back up.
I just feel like...
Hey, Blau.
I have some work for you here.
You have some extra reports to do.
What is this I'm looking at?
Like, here's a smack to you for good luck.
Hey, thanks.
Is that a virus on your computer?
All right.
Buy a banana.
Oh, my gosh.
I'm so hot.
I need a banana.
All right.
That's why you shake your head, my man.
How do we got?
Where's the banana?
Okay.
All right.
Guys, it's Tina.
It's Tina.
She's drinking on the job.
Guys, it's Tina.
I can't believe this.
What?
It's been a hard day of work for everybody.
All right.
You guys want a banana?
No, thank you.
I think an apple.
Where's the apple?
Wait.
Is that a meeting?
Yeah.
That's a meeting.
Oh, no.
He's not calling a meeting.
He doesn't know.
Now you're getting an apple to try to save your Sorya.
Guys, there's beers everywhere.
Look.
This is a really hard job.
I need another beer.
This way.
How do you run?
I got you a beer.
This has been a hard day.
Oh, my goodness.
I told you to put that in the fridge.
What about you?
See?
Your shit is in the fridge.
You had so much.
My coward girl.
Can she speak?
Oh, thank you.
Tina's not here right now.
I know a lot of people are missing.
I mean, you can see.
Tina's drunk.
She's drunk.
I feel like Tina's been a menace this whole time.
Tina?
It's always late to meetings.
It's not a good thing.
You definitely.
I still just kicked someone out who's not a drinker.
Yeah.
Let's do an attendance check.
Tina.
A lot.
Who keeps...
Oh, man.
Tina.
Sorry.
We are disappointed with your behavior.
We're late.
Foolish.
I'm going to say they've been late two times in a row.
Yeah.
They've been late.
It's one of you.
That's awesome.
Who do we vote out?
Huh?
Who?
Which slacker do we get rid of?
One of the two.
It's got to be one of the two.
Guys.
He might even be me.
He might even fire me.
She had a virus on her computer.
Tina.
Oh.
Tina was a worker.
She was a specialist.
Guys.
Okay.
Tina.
I was looking sussy.
I'm not...
I think Tina just doesn't know how to play.
I think she just got hired today.
Okay.
Pick up this.
Sir.
The door is locked, sir.
Oh, my goodness.
Let me unlock that.
Okay.
All right.
Financial.
Let's pick up the financial.
Another financial report?
How many reports do we have?
Okay.
Oh.
I have to shred it.
Executive summary.
This...
Oh.
That's true.
Are we doing something illegal right now?
Don't mind me.
Just picking up after your sorry asses.
Shred.
There we go.
They'll never know that we had a quarter loss.
They'll never know.
Oh.
We have another...
All right.
Another sales confirmation.
Here we go.
Print the sales confirmation.
There's so many.
Which one is it?
Is it this one?
I don't know how to open the door.
Print the sales confirmation.
Pick up.
Have foolish sign the document.
Put it...
Okay.
All right.
Who is it?
I unlocked it.
Wait.
No, you didn't.
It was just in my computer.
I unlocked it.
Did I not unlock this?
No.
Oh.
I unlocked it.
What if you guys are locking it again?
It's locked again.
What's going on?
What's going on in there?
I don't know how it works.
Oh, wait.
That's my form, Blau.
Your eyebrows are red.
I'm not sure if you trust me.
Wait.
Blau, that's my...
Blau, that's my form.
It's item red for Funky Friday.
That's my quarterly report.
The infected Floppy disk.
They're everywhere.
Wait.
Why are you...
What's my form?
Blau, that's my form.
My computer's been blocked.
I'm infected with a virus.
Could I...
Wait.
Is this not mine?
Is this mine?
Which form...
Which form is this?
I can't...
I'm gonna...
Okay.
Wait.
I have a key.
Seriously?
I have another form for you to sign.
It's another quarterly report.
Of course.
Here.
It's right on the ground.
I can get it for you.
Hey.
No worries.
Oh, my God.
How many quarterly reports are in a quarterly report?
You're one of our best workers, Toki.
One day, you're gonna get that promotion.
Oh, my God.
I'm gonna get that promotion?
One day, I'll be a boss just like you?
Yeah.
So, what's up?
Okay.
Oh, my God.
The paper tray.
Oh, dear God.
I gotta put some work there.
Oh, please.
There you go.
I'm doing my job.
I'm nine to five.
I love working at the office.
Thanks.
This is my first job.
Oh, it was on the floor.
It was already on the floor.
Just keep it.
Keep it on the floor.
Hey.
I'll still drink it.
Don't worry.
Keep it on the floor.
Oh, thank you.
Thank you.
It has been a stressful day, let me tell you.
Um.
Good news to bad news.
Bad news...
Um.
You guys as a whole are pretty bad at your jobs.
Wait.
I thought you said I was your best worker.
You.
Yeah.
Hell yeah, Toki.
Yay!
I'm not laughing at it.
Yay.
What.
I'm happy.
Happy.
I'm laughing because I just am mortified that I did that to you.
No, hey, listen.
I really hope that one day we can...
I'm talking.
Janet, um...
Foolish, you got 20 seconds to fire someone.
Janet!
You know what?
We can't be having this.
Oh, I'm sorry.
Get her.
Get her now.
It's disarray.
Foolish, there's only two firings left and two slackers.
If you get another one wrong, you lose the whole game.
We're really gonna need to figure this out.
If we get another one wrong, it's all over at that point.
Alright, you know what?
You know what?
I'm gonna start trying now.
Okay?
I know who the slackers are.
Wait, who are they?
If you know who they are, can you tell us right now?
Oh, I probably shouldn't say that yet though or else, um...
I mean, if you know who they are, just call the meeting right now and vote them off.
But then they could do like a sabotage and then, you know...
Yeah, but if you call the meeting now, they can't do a sabotage.
Up to you.
Oh...
Man, I don't like how you're questioning the boss.
Oh, you're right.
I'm so sorry.
You know it all, manager.
You're right.
We should never question your methods.
Okay.
Alright.
Time to use the bathroom.
Are you using the bathroom?
No, no.
I was just here.
Oh, okay.
Sorry.
Okay, I'll just wait until...
I get a little performance anxiety, you know?
Wait, is this the...
Is this the woman's bathroom?
I think we only have one bathroom.
Are you a new hire?
What does WC mean?
Oh, no.
We have another bathroom.
Wait, why are you in the woman's bathroom?
What are you doing?
What does WC mean?
It means washroom?
With a seat?
Look at this couch.
Why is there a couch in the bathroom?
I don't know.
It's got to absorb too many smells.
Yeah, I was going to say.
There's got to be a lot of stains here.
I'm going to go do my task.
All right, guys.
Guys.
Guys, I need you guys to...
I'm going to mute the game, guys, okay?
I'm going to mute the game.
Guys,
it's not funny.
Guys, it's not funny.
Just using the bathroom.
Please don't listen in.
Okay.
Thank God.
All right.
Guys, it's a little embarrassing.
I get a little performance anxiety.
How do I get out?
Wait, how do I...
How do I...
Oh, thank God.
Okay.
Pick up the sales forecast.
I saw that.
I refilled the toilet paper for the world.
All right.
Grab.
You now have a clean bottom.
Here's the forecast.
Oh, it's right here.
Okay, nice.
Okay.
Well, I don't know what to do with this paper anymore.
Sir, I know that we're about to have a meeting.
I just want to say after the meeting, I actually need you to clear a virus from a PC.
You're the only one who can do it.
Oh, of course.
Of course.
I love doing that.
Oh, my God.
This game is hectic.
I don't want to sit in the...
I don't want to get...
I don't want him to fire me, so I'm going to sit in the back.
I think...
No.
Come on.
I don't know.
We've been through a lot this past week.
You know?
Yup.
Foolish is a slacker!
What?
I'm not a slacker!
Foolish can't be a slacker.
He's the manager.
That's insane to assume of our great leader.
Yeah, yeah.
You know, I think Valkyrie might be the slacker for calling him out as a slacker.
I literally ordered paper reams for the company!
Why are we doing paper reams?
What did you say?
Paper reams?
I think paper reams are literally just printing papers.
Ray thinks I'm a schlocker because I have a virus on my PC which I need the manager to handle.
Yeah, but what if you put the virus on yourself?
Oh boy, oh boy.
When in doubt, you know who to go with.
Oh.
Oh my god.
Wow, I did not expect that.
Wow.
Wow, I think we lost.
I think the stock prices are falling, Mr. Manager.
There's a server outage.
Guys, so basically, because there's two slackers left and there's one termination left, we lose automatically.
We lose automatically.
Oops.
Well.
I didn't do that.
Okay, paper ream.
What is a paper ream anyway?
Guys, we gotta sell.
We have to sell the stock, guys.
It's crashing right now.
Guys, we got...
What is that word call when you bet against the stock?
Guys, it's time to short the stock, guys.
It's time to short the stock.
What is even the point of working?
We're gonna get fired anyway.
We're gonna get fired.
How is it me?
I'm just doing my work.
It doesn't matter.
We're gonna...
We're gonna get fired.
There's another meeting?
No, no, I think that's the fire alarm.
I think there's a fire.
There's a fire.
Why is there a fire?
You would have gotten away with it too.
You would have gotten away with it.
Janitor, put out the fire.
What are you doing?
Did you get trained?
What do you mean?
Oh my god, how do you use this?
I don't know.
I think it's empty.
I was just throwing things in the garbage.
Why are you putting music on?
That's how you got trained in janitor school.
Why are you...
That sucks.
Drop and roll.
Guys, we fixed it.
We fixed the fire.
I saved the company.
Guys, do you guys know there's a meeting?
Yeah.
We should go to that then.
Oh my god.
Everybody's sake comp starts breakdancing.
Guys, I had to put out the fire.
The janitor did not go to janitor school.
I am gonna take responsibility.
I haven't been the best.
And I should have chosen a better assistant.
It's all his fault.
This is insane.
I freaking knew it was blow.
When he started spanking.
Yeah.
What did we get?
Money?
Yeah, you can buy cosmetics.
Dude, that's nice.
We were gonna win.
Who snitched on me?
Why did they snitch on me?
Tina is the most slacker slacker that's not a slacker I've ever seen.
I think Tina didn't know how to play.
I think she was learning.
She didn't know.
I was just watching and she had no idea.
Dude, it's such a mess.
It just looks like everyone's walking and running around.
I don't know how to say a random name.
How was I supposed to figure it out?
That's the best part.
You aren't supposed to.
Yeah.
And then even when I asked Tina who started the fire, she was like, uh, it was Lily.
Like, why is she saying it like that?
It was.
Yeah, but it was.
But it was Lily, though.
Join, guys, join.
Maybe we should have longer meetings then.
So we can actually...
You fired me!
Yeah, that's what you get for snitching.
There was one round left, no matter what, and I figured I should fire you.
Tina, you're gonna need to step it up if you ever want to make it as assistant manager.
Wait, assistant manager?
She already got promoted, but all she did was slack!
What if Tina actually became the manager this time?
She also had the floppy disk.
It's like, who's always thrown around trashy fire right in front of me.
And I was so confused.
How do I join the lobby?
Which volume?
Stolen credit.
I can't believe they stole my credit!
She didn't know how to pick up the fire!
So which one?
You want to raise the volume of the game or discord chat?
I'm giving you the power.
I'm giving you the power, Mio.
You guys want to raise the volume of the game or the discord chat?
Oh, that's gonna be great.
We are missing Lily.
Huh?
Oh, my bad.
Promotion always goes to the most capital.
Hold on, how do I join?
We are missing...
Are we going to New York?
Or is it Ohio?
There are other maps.
There's like the recreation of...
Like from the office?
Yeah, there's the office map.
Whoa!
Yeah, like one of the tasks is to put Jello in the stapler too.
Wait, that's awesome.
I could be Pam.
You could be!
I'm gonna be Pam.
I'm Pam coded, I'm not gonna lie.
Ready up, ready up, ready up.
The extra greeting.
I did so much!
This is what it's like to work at 9 to 5!
It doesn't matter how hard you work!
It's all about the network!
This is fucked.
It doesn't matter how hard you work!
It's just how you know people and how you fucking...
Welcome to the office life!
It's all about nepotism!
What do you mean?
What's that got to do with anything?
Am I unmuted?
Yeah.
We have our new manager.
The microphone turns on like slightly.
What's dangerous?
I aspire to do something wonderful.
Alright.
Can't wait to start my day working in my favorite company.
Best day of my life.
Alright.
Snake.
Best day of my life.
No!
Mike!
I was doing important work and there's no connection already?
Oh, the screen.
Sorry guys.
Sorry.
Guys, I need...
The server is out guys.
Oh!
She already got promoted!
I knew it's all about...
I knew it.
Nepotism.
I called nepotism!
Tina, who are we firing now?
We don't have to.
We have two minutes left.
We have two minutes.
Someone's gonna be on the chopping board, guys.
Yeah, let's have an orientation.
We have 30 seconds.
I gotta do some work.
Okay, what's your work, man?
You know what?
You two...
Worst managers I've ever seen.
Alright, let's get this guy out of here.
I don't like this calendar.
I'm down.
Slacker again!
And twice in a row!
LM, I think you gotta fix your reputation, LM.
You're never gonna play the game.
You're never gonna be able to work.
Excellent work.
That's to be expected of me.
Tina, I'm so happy you got promoted.
You did amazing.
I know!
Why don't we shake hands?
I mean, I deserve that, but...
Oh, thank you!
Can we shake hands, Ms. Assistant Manager?
For a good job that you got promoted?
Yeah!
Good job!
I always knew you got this!
I always knew you totally deserved that job!
Thank you so much!
I hope the same for you!
What do you want?
What?
Oh, cats!
Wait, what's the bathroom?
Where's the cats?
Oh, the cats are over here.
Alright.
Brown...
Activated.
Guys, what are you guys doing in the server room?
Thank you so much!
I got it!
Alright, nice, I fixed it.
Alright, pet the cats.
Hello, little kitties.
Hello.
Oh, another meeting?
Why do we have so many meetings, Ms. Manager?
Oh, I know exactly who the slacker is.
Oh!
Who is it?
Uh, I'm gonna let them confess their sins first.
Oh!
That's bold of you.
That's really bullsy.
Tina...
Alright, name who the slacker is.
I thought you knew who the slacker is, Ms. Manager.
Oh, I know, but I'm gonna let Tina take it away.
Yeah, Tina, you obviously know who the slacker is too!
What?
That's slacker behavior!
That could be like... Isn't that like a homie thing?
You bros poop together?
Isn't that what bros do?
That's a lie.
Why are you lying?
And who is it, Dino?
Who is it?
I make the dimes, that's why I poop on company time.
Is that right, Dino?
No, no, no.
Yeah, yeah.
Did you poop on company time?
Oh, Mia, you gotta vote someone out.
Mia, please.
Because I have a raise that I worked hard for.
Oh, oh.
Oh, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha.
Okay, to be fair, uh...
Oh, Dino.
Oh.
Oh, brother, this is unbelievable.
Damn, Dino.
Oh, I got Ray.
Sorry, Dino.
Assistant Ray, nice.
It is what it is.
Congratulations on the promotion.
Yeah, congratulations on the promotion.
You're a disappointment.
Thank God Tina got demoted.
She didn't deserve that job.
She didn't fucking deserve it.
She didn't deserve it.
Okay, they won't know I'm playing Minesweeper, guys.
How would they know?
Okay.
Okay, there we go.
How would they know?
Okay, I won the game.
There we go.
This is how you...
This is how you play the game.
Bro, I can't with these locked doors.
Uh, hey, Mia.
Um...
Oh.
I can't go anywhere.
It was me.
Okay, I need a...
Locking the doors.
I need a...
Let's open the door.
Wait, yeah, who keeps managers?
Someone...
We need doors open.
Welcome to working at a nine-to-five.
This is why we're streamers.
Hey, does everyone know I show those desks?
Come, come, look at my desks.
Where are the keys?
Oh, there's a fire.
There's a fire.
Work without my map.
Where's the fire?
There's a fire.
This is my desk.
Oh, Alan, did you start the fire?
Where's the fire extinguisher?
Chad, he started the fire.
All right, all right, here we go.
All right, here we go.
It's okay, it's okay.
The company is saved.
Stock prices continue to...
Hey, nice, nice.
...to this entire office.
Oh, my God.
What does that mean?
Come this way.
Oh, you know what it means, right?
Oh, my God.
I need to shake hands with somebody.
What's the point?
What's the fucking point?
We're gonna lose anyway.
What's the point?
We're gonna get fired anyway.
Let's just drink it all.
Another fi...
Okay, I give up.
Let's break it down.
Oh, yeah.
It started the fire.
This is it.
This is our shit.
I don't know.
Oh, my God.
Oh, it's fire.
What's she gonna do?
Fire us?
Oh, no.
What's she gonna do?
Oh, my God.
I'm out.
It's too much work.
Okay.
I'm opening it.
This is too much.
I can't.
That's crazy.
Okay.
Well, Ray, do you have anything?
Oh, yes.
I saw Foolish run through the server room and he started the server thing.
He started the server thing?
You were in the room before.
I guess I...
Well, I guess he didn't even know that I was lying down here.
Manager, I saw Foolish trying to hotbox the staff room.
I saw Foolish start a fire in the trash can in the office.
Wow.
I guess something is everywhere.
If it's Foolish, then it can't be Foolish.
It's gotta be Foolish.
Yeah, I saw him start a fire.
I saw him start two fires.
Just kill me.
Just kill me, bro.
Don't do it, Miong.
Don't do it.
Oh!
Oh, wow.
She was a slacker.
She was.
There's only one.
Yeah.
That's what I saw, LM.
You really...
You really outed Ray for that.
Hey, thank you, Mono.
I can't believe it.
Wait.
Where's Pam?
I thought we had a Pam.
Oh, LM was promoted?
You can get promoted.
But he was a janitor.
Wait.
What do we...
Fire.
Oh!
The plant loves this.
We'll transform this into Oxygen for us.
I'm getting him out.
Just send more Monster up!
How do I...
Post this?
Anonymous...
Anonymous letter...
What?
What's going on here?
Anonymous letter.
What am I supposed to do?
Oh, it's another fucking meeting.
Are you fucking kidding me?
Please, I can't get my job.
I can't get my job!
What am I supposed to do?
Why can't I get an E-Test done?
Okay.
Find another quick meeting.
Okay, um...
Goki, why are you littering everywhere?
What's going on?
It's just I'm so overworked.
I signed so many reports and so many quarterly reports.
I literally picked up the quarterly report but it doesn't matter because we have a meeting.
What does it matter?
Why did you put fire foolish like the sticky note on the ground?
Oh, I found it.
I found it on the floor so I just put it there.
Okay.
That sounds like a useful hint.
You're looking great today, Ms. Mannequin.
So...
Yeah, what else did you do today?
Did you do something with your eyebrows?
Did you get them tattooed?
Be honest.
You just look so good today.
Okay.
Thank you, man.
I appreciate that.
No problem, no problem.
Oh, meeting's over!
Yay!
You don't have to, no.
She can call another meeting.
I have to pick up trash?
Okay.
Always laughing at you getting bullied.
Where's my...
Listen.
Where's trash?
Any trash?
Our janitor's not doing their work.
Okay.
You know, all those games that they said...
Trash.
I heard that was the number one OLED gaming monitor in the US.
Oh my god, I can't believe so many...
There's so many mouse trash.
How do I... How do I...
Throw this... Okay, there you go.
I threw it away.
Okay, I need a soda.
I need a soda.
I need a...
Beer on the ground is not trash, it's a lifestyle.
It's trash.
There's... Oh, I already got a soda.
Alright.
Oh my god.
I can't.
Boom!
How do we get in there?
Yeah, where?
The server room?
It's here.
Oh, no, there's another meeting.
It's corporate life.
So many meetings.
But I love that.
I will pass if there is someone here and I don't want to do it.
But it has to be done.
LM, just shut up.
Shut up.
Oh my god.
You're doing great, Ms. Manager.
You might have to go.
For what?
Wait, I've been great.
Wait, what did he do?
We've been working together.
Yeah, I saw them working.
You might have to go.
Wait, but I've been so good too.
I literally shred paper.
Yeah, I saw that too.
I saw her feed cats.
I saw her...
Call her out, Shoto.
I didn't see that.
Saw her what?
I saw her do stuff on her computer and do like inventory.
I've seen you shred paper once.
Okay, I'm going to leave this to Foolish.
He was it.
Oh.
Great question.
Who here knows about viruses?
I don't think we have time.
I think Foolish should stop.
Where did that come from?
Where was that shot?
Where was that shot from?
Oh my god.
I think I know who it is.
Wait, who is it?
Who is it?
I think I know who it is.
Oh, hey, Lily.
Alright, I got to put the...
Good job.
Good job, everybody.
Another good job.
Well done.
Okay.
Guys, I'm going to pull an epic pet prank, guys.
It's going to be so epic.
People are going to find it so fucking funny.
Guys, people are going to find it so fucking funny.
Oh my god, who did that?
What is this?
We should put it on a bulletin board.
Let's put it on the bulletin board.
Right here.
Okay.
Oh, look at that.
Look at you.
I'm going to sign it.
Oh.
Oh, it was Saikudo.
Oh, we won.
Yeah, we won.
Where the fuck is Aleph?
He didn't even come.
I'm done with you, you motherfucker.
Oh, how d'you...
Go away.
How d'you...
I've never seen you strong.
Aleph.
How d'you...
Go away.
Oh, my gosh.
Just...
So hard!
I'm sorry.
It doesn't make any sense!
I was late to the meeting.
He crashed it out, Brad.
He straight up got himself out.
And then got me and Ray out.
It was crazy.
Dude, if Elef's imposter...
If I'm imposter with him, I'm actually alt f4-ing.
I actually am.
Wait, wait.
How did Elef call a psychudo?
What happened?
Dude, he threw me under the bus.
What did he do?
He threw himself out first round.
He threw me out next round.
And then me after that.
I can't help it if you guys are all bad at being the imposter.
You know, what am I meant to do?
Dude, I'm a great assistant here.
You make me want to gouge my eyes out.
And then you snip.
Not the slacker trying to play foolish.
That was crazy.
This is an intentional bingo at this point.
It's a reverse bingo, Shadow.
It's a reverse bingo.
That's not it.
I want to apologize to you, but I actually can't.
I'm so mad.
No, I'm not apologizing.
Better hope he's not manager next round.
We can vote him out as manager.
Remember, guys?
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah, you can vote out the manager.
Manager.
You can't be trusted anywhere.
LM, give the manager to somebody else.
Oh, yeah.
No, I'm going to give the manager to someone.
That's for sure.
We already know who it is.
Who is it?
I think we're missing two people.
Oh, shit.
Coming.
Tina and Janet.
I was customizing.
Me too.
Wait, you customize your characters?
Yeah, you can.
You can customize your characters.
So, go back to the main lobby.
I need money.
You've been getting some in the game.
Yeah.
I spent it all already.
Guys, I drew a picture on my computer and printed it out and then Janet and Donkey hung it up on the wall.
Yeah.
It's like a child getting a picture hanged on the fridge.
Do it again.
Do it again, please.
And they were like, oh my gosh, that's amazing.
We're like the mom and dad.
We're like, oh, congratulations.
Whoa, guys.
I guess I'll be the manager.
Oh.
Ellen, you are doing an amazing job, Ellen.
I think.
Ellen, great job, Ellen.
Good job.
I'm going to raise out to get you.
I guess I got to call a meeting now.
Ellen, you're not muted, Ellen.
You're not muted on Discord.
Sorry.
I'm ready.
Okay.
Shake my hand.
It's been a good one, man.
It's been a good one.
Are we having an orientation?
Oh, wait.
Is it four?
Give me one good reason.
Don't you dare touch her.
Fire me.
Here, I'll give you a reason.
Back away.
Is that what you want to do?
You know that's what he wants to do, Ray.
You know that's what he wants to do.
He's already done it twice.
No.
We already let this happen.
Oh.
Why?
Wait, she was imposter.
Okay.
Oh, good job.
Well, you're really good at this job.
Wait, yeah.
Maybe you're really good at magic.
Good job.
You did great.
Thank you so much.
Excellent work.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Tina?
No, I do.
I just loaded you out and you were imposter.
Yeah, I don't know what I'm supposed to do.
It was sick, actually.
Yeah, I'm sorry.
I'm sorry, Tina, that this happened to you.
Well, no, too bad, because you fired me, so now you all have a computer.
Oh, fuck.
Enjoy your new job as a judge.
He's a slacker and he fired his teammate.
Whoa.
Shut up.
Don't say that.
Listen, let's think.
He always hints his teammates when he's a slacker.
Okay, true.
And this is the best way to convince you he's innocent.
Let's pretend to feed the cat.
Do you think that made him look better?
Why is there still a fire?
Do they not realize there was a fire?
Do you think he knew somehow?
There was no hint.
The game just started.
He voted out his own teammate to try and convince him.
Guys, I don't think they realized there was a fire right next to them.
You know what?
I'm voting against him.
Vote against!
Oh, it got put out.
That was fast.
Okay, that was really fast.
Okay.
Oh, it's the same one!
Alright, let's see.
It's gonna be so funny.
Where's my drink?
Alright, we're gonna...
We're gonna get some coffee.
Wait, that's not coffee.
Oh, I need to grab... Oh, beer!
Alright, don't worry.
I have a plan, guys.
I'm gonna grab the beer.
I'm gonna drink the beer.
And then...
I'm gonna give the beer to...
I'm gonna give the beer to the manager.
Don't worry.
And then...
He won't suspect a thing.
Is that Garfield?
Wait, what?
Why is there me?
Okay, I'm gonna drop this.
We're the framers.
Vote for what?
I didn't vote!
What are we voting for?
Is it vote against?
Yeah, vote for.
Vote for because we're replacing.
Yeah!
Oh, the server!
It's the server!
Oh wait, that's not the server.
No, no, no, no, no.
It's the...
It's the meeting, I think.
I think the manager has to do a meeting, but he doesn't know.
Okay.
Let's get to it!
What do you have, Dakin?
Yeah, you snitched on me.
You're taking the shit for Shoto.
What did I snitch on you?
At the last firm.
I'm not even talking to you, honestly.
At the last firm?
You know what?
It smells...
Still, Dakin, could you actually move back a step?
Move back a step!
Did you?
Right then!
You stink!
LM, there are people voting to replace you.
He's landering his employees!
Do it now!
Congratulations!
I always believe you'll get there!
You need to fire someone.
I didn't fire someone!
I always believed in you.
Did you...
Did you think... Okay, well...
Yeah, we could've talked in a little bit.
Yeah, you had time.
You sort of had time.
Yeah.
You know, it's kind of crazy that you guys are all telling me all of this.
Janet, I think you did a great job, Janet.
I think you did a great job, and honestly, like, you didn't deserve the pressure.
You didn't deserve it.
This is your first day.
This is your first try, you know?
Excellent work.
Wait, how do I...
How do I clap?
Of course, of course, Ms. Manager.
I'm watching over every...
I'm watching over every single one of you.
Okay, I need to start a fire.
What?
The printer is, like, back here.
Isn't it all the way over here?
It's over here!
Oh wait, no, that's not it.
It's over here.
It's a copier room.
Yeah, see?
See?
I knew it.
I told you I knew it.
Alright.
Jenna, I think you're doing a great job.
In my country, that's a compliment.
Oh, thank you so much.
Yeah, yeah.
Okay.
No, why do I always have to drink?
I'm tired of drinking!
I'm so fucking tired!
I don't want to drink anymore!
I'm becoming an alcoholic!
Wait.
Wait, where's my...
I don't want to...
You got me fired at the last friend.
I don't want to be...
I don't want to be an alcoholic anymore!
I want to pretend to work for real!
I'm tired!
I'm tired of being an alcoholic!
I'm so tired!
I don't want to be an alcoholic anymore!
Ty, you're better than me.
Uh, I kinda am.
Wait, what are you on?
Is that your desk?
Oh, yeah, that is your desk.
Yeah, we're desk buddies.
Look, we're desk buddies!
Wait, is this...
Wait, what's going on?
I'm trying to call the manager, but she won't pick up the phone.
Is that a fire?
I'm trying to call the manager.
No, that's the meeting.
Why is my manager not picking it up?
Oh!
I don't want to...
I'm trying to call...
Who do you...
Who do you think...
Well, there's people not in the meeting right now.
Janet, you have time.
I'm not gonna lie.
I thought it was a fire.
I kinda got confused.
No, you don't.
Yes, I did.
Okay.
Oh, you got time.
Can you sign this?
Yes.
Let's see.
Oh!
It's okay.
She learned that from me.
In my country, it's a compliment.
Oh, she's your manager.
Oh!
That was a move.
Yeah, yeah.
She's the manager in HR, so you can't complain.
My turn.
Okay.
Oh!
Thank you.
Okay.
Even though I signed that for you, MeeYang, I can't help but notice that I stood behind your shoulder and you were playing Minesweeper, and I know Neutrals can play Minesweeper, but like you were enjoying it a little too much.
No, that's...
Yeah.
You should be...
No way!
She needs a break.
She just needed a break.
Okay.
But on company time, we have break rooms for a reason.
We have break rooms for a reason.
Okay.
For the good of the company.
Oh, no.
Okay.
Oh, you can't see that.
Goodbye, Janet.
Goodbye.
For the good of the company.
Where did Shoto go?
Shoto isn't even in the meeting!
Oh, Shoto!
You deserved it.
Congratulations on your promotion.
Congrats.
Oh, thank you so much.
Congratulations.
Oh, sorry.
I sat down.
I sat down because I wanted to give you a clap for your promotion.
Congratulations.
You did your best, honestly.
You know?
Oh, we have to fix the server.
Wait!
Foolish, did you crash the server?
No, no, no!
I've been monitoring because it takes like 10 seconds, okay?
So Shoto walked in here at the very beginning and then came back, so I think it has to be Shoto.
Wait, Shoto, did you crash...
Shoto, did you saw who crashed the server?
I am the manager.
What do you mean?
Yeah!
Foolish said it was you that... Foolish is trying to blame the manager.
I didn't believe him.
Why are you trying to blame the manager?
Don't spank me!
Don't spank me.
Stupid, stupid, ugly.
So ugly.
Oh, shit.
Okay, I'm going to pretend to do work, guys.
Where's my PC?
Okay, I'm going to call the manager.
Do you think the manager will take the call?
Hello?
I'm trying to call the manager.
I'm trying to call the manager right now.
I have problems.
I need the manager to sort it out.
Hello?
Manager?
Is that you?
Hello?
He hanged up!
He hanged up the phone!
Mr.
Manager, why did you hang up on my call?
I had a very important call.
Okay, I'll give you a hint, Shoto.
It's a Star Rail character.
Sparkle.
Sparkle?
Oh, blue!
Dude, he's just thinking about Sparkle.
He's got a problem.
How about all the blues?
I mean, she is one of my favorites.
Zilla!
Yeah!
Oh, yeah!
Wait!
Yeah, you did get it!
Nice!
Oh, wait!
I didn't need to do that!
Damn!
You're already demoting?
Oh, damn!
Call a meeting!
No, we're already in a meeting.
He only likes Sparkle.
I see.
It's okay.
No, you have another... Yeah, you can... You have time.
You have time.
He called the meeting so we could look at the beautiful bulletin board, right?
Is that it?
Wait, wait.
Wait, Foolish, you look a little tired.
I have a hunch who it is.
You wanna get some coffee?
Alright, put it in pick up.
Oh!
What if I infected my own PC?
How do I... Oh, I... Good job.
Good job, Doki.
Good job.
You did great.
Oh!
I didn't have to do anything.
What's going on?
What is that?
Sticky note you have there.
I'm watching you.
Tina, what... What are you doing?
Are you harassing a worker?
No, no, no.
No, she's harassing somebody!
Look what she dropped!
Vote Shoto out!
We gotta vote Shoto out!
Oh, vote Shoto out?
Yeah, yeah.
Thank you.
Vote Shoto out!
Fast!
Alright, alright.
Vote him out.
You gotta fire her!
Wait, who taught us this, man?
Oh.
This is not good.
Oh!
Wait a second.
The goat.
And why did he...
Terminate... Oh!
Oh, it's cause we're still in the meeting!
You still have a chance!
We're still in the meeting!
Okay, uh, this is really...
Wait, we're already dead.
Zero terminations.
We're done.
We're over.
It's cooked.
No, but the meeting is in progress.
You can do... You can hit one more shot.
The meeting is in progress.
Well, Sakuto got two people voted out when they were specialists.
Wait, I did?
When did I do that?
Yes, you got... Oh...
You got...
I wish I did.
I don't think I have the... the credit.
It's over.
Oh, that's a good job.
Oh.
What?
We cried!
Wait, how did you guys...
We're all the specialists.
That ain't...
We're all managers.
My god, I thought Sakuto was sus.
Yes!
I mean, it was just Sakuto, really.
How did they... they voted for every specialist except for...
Can a limited poster guy ever become manager?
I don't think so, right?
Yes.
Oh.
Wait, really?
What?
Did I make that up?
Wait, wasn't Janet one?
You can be an assistant, but I don't think you can be a manager.
No, you... No, like, slackers can't be managers.
Only assistants.
You can never be manager.
Were you just red, then?
Uh, I guess so.
I think so.
Yeah.
I was good, though.
Oh, I thought you were a bad guy this whole time.
I thought we were in for a hoon.
What is that?
What the...
That's helpful information.
Oh, chat says managers... slackers can't be managers.
Never.
Yes, slackers can't be managers.
Oh.
You didn't know that.
Janet was role-playing that she was gonna take my job, and two minutes later, she took my job.
She just worked harder, LM.
What can I say?
Yeah.
She just worked harder, man.
Yeah, she just... she just worked a little harder.
I manifested that sh!t.
New map, new map.
Oh yeah, is there any specific ones you guys want?
Is there any we haven't done yet?
Denmark.
We can do that one.
Yeah, let's do it.
Oh, wait, wait.
I'm not in.
I'm coming.
Oh, I need to go in.
We are missing...
I'm on the way!
I'm in!
Could you only speak Danish the whole time?
Honestly, I'll be out of time.
Wait, are we in Denmark now?
We're in Denmark.
Oh my god, we all got our visas.
Copenhagen!
We are missing one person.
Are you ready?
Who's the one person that's missing?
Let's lose it out.
I'm willing to guess it.
It's Shodo.
Good sleuthing, good sleuthing.
I would like to take a moment to...
Probably taking a shower.
I'm right here.
Taking a shower is crazy.
You need a food break.
Working in the office is very stressful.
We all need a food break.
Spick and span.
Dinner just showed up.
That's supposed to make sense.
Spick and span.
No, that makes sense.
What does that mean?
Spick and span.
You're saying that like that solved everything.
It does solve everything.
When we get into the next game.
Ready.
I'm ready.
You can have 21 players?
Oh my god.
I can't imagine.
It's always Tina.
21 players but nobody is going to get work done.
I thought that the no lines meant I was ready.
Yeah, I know.
Because the other one means you're crossed out.
So you're not ready.
No, it's like you're crossed in.
Check the box.
Don't get me mad at you.
I hope I'm not mad at you.
Oh, nice.
Alright, guys.
I'm good.
Who's that?
Congratulations.
Even though you already promoted assistant, I still say congratulations.
You did amazing.
I knew you deserved it.
You worked so hard.
Manager, the door has been locked.
Get her out of here, guys.
Okay, meeting starting.
Are we having orientation?
I don't know.
I guess so.
Is this normal?
Hello, new manager.
Of course you did.
Everything you do is intentional, right, manager?
You know what you're doing.
You're the best.
Thank you so much.
The manager can do no wrong.
True.
We can't miss our first meeting at a new company.
Of course.
We're here for our orientation.
Manager, when will we get our sensitivity training?
Everyone applaud now.
Applaud for our manager.
Of course.
I'll hail our new manager.
Everyone applaud.
If you're not applauding, you're probably slacking off on the job.
That's what I think.
I'm really drunk.
No, you have time.
Just end it.
It's just an orientation.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Thank you so much for the applause.
Saikuno is holding the keys and being a manager.
Please take care.
Me too.
I love working here.
It's my favorite job.
Maybe we have to get the coach to try.
Where's my PC?
Wait, that was my PC.
Yes!
That was my PC.
Okay.
Back to work I go.
Wait, I got my own office.
They'll never know.
Oh my god.
I got my own office.
How could they tell?
That was my task.
I have an evil task above it.
Do I have to contact HR?
We have HR?
Wait, who's our HR?
I'm having a little drink right now.
Who's our HR?
What about you guys?
Jenner's just the HR.
Jenner, you're HR?
What's wrong?
I have an HR complaint.
Somebody started a fire.
What happened?
Somebody started a fire, Ms. HR.
Why would you call this before the fire happened?
I put out the fire.
Don't worry, I put out the fire.
Interesting.
Wait, where's the manager?
Not like...
Just for the sake of it.
Everyone aboard!
Hurry, we start off the meetings with a plotting to the manager.
Oh yeah, you're right.
You're the best.
Best manager, honestly.
Sock prices are rising because of your decisions, Ms. Ray.
I'll have you know, our stock prices rose 20% today.
Only because of Ray.
Wait, wait, can I talk?
Guys, let's not...
I think it was...
It was Janet, and it was Shoto.
We saw...
We could easily vote out out of fire.
I said out of fire.
Wait, how did I?
What?
I was just saying HR.
I was calling HR.
And then a fire showed up.
No!
Wait, how?
I actually did nothing.
I didn't start the fire.
I didn't even start the fire.
And then it was trying to call HR.
I can't believe it.
I didn't even start the fire.
I got blamed.
My team betrayed me.
I'm gonna fucking put everybody...
thing in jello.
Fuck this.
I'm gonna start every fire.
I'm gonna put everybody's thing in jello now.
That's fucking right.
This is your fault.
I did nothing wrong.
Great, great, yeah.
You know, the stay at home dad.
Just taking care of the kids.
It's a lovely life.
What's your son's name?
I can't even start the fire.
What's the point?
This is it.
This Janner is going fucking rogue.
This Janner is gonna put everything in jello.
Nobody can stop me.
That's right.
Jello.
Everybody's thing is gonna be in jello.
I fucking hate my job.
I hate my job.
I get paid.
I was the fucking supervisor.
I had the perfect office.
I had everything.
I'm starting every goddamn fire.
I don't work here anymore.
So I don't even have cigarettes.
I gonna steal this person's cigarette.
I'm gonna make sure nobody's gonna have a good time.
Fuck this job.
Okay.
I'm smoking.
I'm gonna fucking hate this job so much.
All I do is work.
Thank you.
I am a job.
I can't get nothing out of it.
It doesn't matter.
It doesn't fucking matter.
I can't even take their fucking mouse.
How the fuck do I take his mouse?
I can't even take the mouse!
Oh, I can.
Okay.
Nobody deserves anything.
Nobody deserves...
Nobody deserves to work anymore.
Nobody deserves to work.
Nobody...
Nobody deserves to work anymore.
I refuse to let anybody work here.
You like my stash?
I'm running a mouse black market.
Have you not been fired already?
I'm a janitor.
I got demoted.
It doesn't matter how hard I work.
I didn't even start the fire.
You know who started it?
It was fucking LM that started the fire.
I was just next door.
I was actually working.
Doesn't matter.
He does find a way to ruin it for all sides, really.
Doesn't matter how hard I work.
It doesn't matter.
You just get fired.
You go in.
You clock in.
You clock out.
And then no matter how hard you work, you still get fired.
What's the point in life anymore?
Weren't you one of the imposters anyway?
Yeah, but I did an imposter.
I was just existing.
I was congratulating our wonderful manager.
Anyway, you guys need mouse?
I'm running a black market.
Yeah, well...
It comes with a price.
Oh, okay.
Look, it's like...
It's like, you know...
Like $50.
$50?
$50, yeah.
Dude, the way we're getting paid here, you think I can afford that?
Oh, no.
The meeting.
The meeting!
Wanna make sure he doesn't get this mouse.
Alright.
Oh, wait.
Okay, I'm gonna make sure nobody gets to work.
I'm gonna make sure nobody will find this.
How would they expect it?
Alright.
I'll go to the meeting.
Where's the meeting room?
Oh, there it is.
Hey, I mentioned you've done your own thing.
Yeah.
You can't just...
Ask me a question.
Ask me a question an innocent person would know.
Ask me.
Wait.
I'm already fired.
You can't...
Please.
I already worked so hard.
What do you mean?
I'm already...
I'm already insanity.
I can't believe it.
You know what?
I will ride out my imposter buddy.
You'll regret it, I tell you.
Whoa.
What?
What was you?
I don't know.
Okay, I got two more tries.
Two more tries.
I mean...
I'm sorry.
Oh, you're right.
They won't know where the fire extinguisher is either.
They won't know.
The sun gets bullied.
It's so sad.
They won't know.
Doki, I hope you're having a lovely day.
And I'm so sorry that you got fired earlier.
Then why didn't you defend me?
Because...
Why didn't you defend...
You know how...
You know how hard I work every day.
I'm sorry.
Every day.
On the job.
Every other...
One day, I decided to slack off.
And you didn't defend me.
You were bad the other day, too.
When I was the manager.
No!
Let's be real.
Don't you remember when we hung that picture on the bulletin board?
We did.
That was the one day you were a very good worker.
And you didn't defend me.
That's so true.
Actually, we did have a moment.
We did have a moment.
Yeah!
And I'm so sorry.
And in the future, I will always defend you.
Always?
Always.
Tomorrow's a new day.
Okay.
Tomorrow.
You said it.
Tomorrow's a new day.
You think I can be a...
You think I can get promoted back to a regular worker?
Yes.
I will...
I'll bring it up to them.
Oh, yeah.
You'll talk to the manager, right?
To get my promotion back?
You have my word.
Yes.
Oh, thank you.
Thank you.
I really appreciate it.
You're so welcome.
Yes.
I have like...
I have like 10 dogs I need to take care of.
And Dejan, their salary's not it.
Wow.
Ah.
Well, like, you know...
You know, time's tough right now.
So, like, I'm trying to have like a mouse black market.
You know?
So, like, people can buy off extra mouse from me.
And so, for the extra money, you know, janitor work isn't...
It's like barely minimum wage, you know?
Like, I have...
Well, I really, really respect this grind.
I really do.
Do you need a fire extinguisher?
I don't.
But as soon as I hear that someone does or a mouse, I'll bring it to you.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
You'll vouch for me, right?
I'll bring it to the bathroom.
All right.
Nice.
I got you.
That's so real.
This is too real.
I got to keep up my underground, my black market.
Janitors deserve more.
We do.
I was like, this is ridiculous.
You know?
It's like...
Oh, yeah.
Close your eyes.
Okay.
Yeah, we'll just work on your anti-airs then.
I fucking hate anti-air.
Thank you so much.
Why are we talking about this?
It's street fighting.
I just put out a fire.
Thank you so much.
All right.
Someone...
You know, maybe...
The servers went out at that last second, right?
The server went down and you distracted me from my post.
I could've got them.
I could've got them if you didn't doubt me.
I know you're innocent because you were talking to Lily when the server went down.
You could just...
There's only one slacker left, so it has to be...
For one second, I was distracted.
Unbelievable.
It has to be Dopey.
It has to be me.
I'm sorry.
I can't read Dopey's heart.
I literally called out...
I called out...
I put out a fire just then.
I've been doing so much.
Guys, let's not forget Shoto was in the vicinity.
You know what?
I'm gonna call out...
I'm gonna call out the slacker.
I will throw my slacker under the bus if I get promoted.
Let's remember that.
Let's remember that, guys.
Important.
Useful.
No, I was with Dopey.
I was with Dopey.
Wait, wait, wait.
If you promote me to assistant, I'll be promoted.
And give me my job back.
Oh.
So maybe it's Shoto.
Wait, what?
Janet?
You know what?
Foolish.
Wow.
I think it's foolish.
It's not me.
That happens.
Ray, Ray.
If you give me assistant, I will throw my slacker buddy under the bus.
It was Shoto.
He's getting defensive.
Let's see your test.
Shoto jellied my stapler.
What task do you have, Shoto?
Can you please open the door?
Open the door.
He's getting defensive.
No.
No, it was me.
I jellied yours.
You jellied everybody's thing.
No, I.
Why are you laughing?
I mean it's okay.
No, it's because I jellied everybody's thing.
I jellied.
Wait.
Oh, wait.
I don't know.
I jellied like five people.
So I thought it was me.
I jellied five different people walking around.
What did you gain from this?
I am a janitor.
I have nothing else in my life.
I am barely getting paid the bare minimum.
You want to see all the people I jellied?
I jellied like five different people.
Here's one.
I jellied Foolish.
I jellied a Zicuno.
So why do we think it's not Zicuno?
Alright,
let's see.
Don't do it.
It's not worth it.
Just don't do the bare minimum.
It's never worth it.
Where's the server room?
What if I just turn off the...
Can I actually turn off the server as a...
Oh, I can.
I wanna watch that full video, though, after this.
I love how he is unmuted.
Okay.
Alright.
She knew about my plan to camp the server room, and in one second, I'm not camping it.
But I was with...
Who could do that?
I just have a chance for it to pop up on their own computer.
By the way, my favorite thing...
Ellum's having his own conversation.
My favorite thing this entire day was literally that one little bit of dialogue with Foolish.
Oh, no.
Not Ellum.
Thanks for the information.
Oh, shit.
I thought it was Ellum, but it was Blau.
Oh, I can't sabotage the server.
That's fucking right.
You're never gonna get your tasks done.
We'll never have our quarterly report.
That's right.
We'll never have the quarterly report.
Wait, why are you drinking, Tina?
What's going on?
I got a drink with the garbage.
Where are you going?
That's my job.
Are you gonna take my job too, Tina?
Are you trying to take my... Everybody got fired.
Are you trying to take my job?
You're not doing your job, Tina.
You're not doing your job.
I am!
There's so much trash!
Holy motherfucker!
I'M NOT DOING MY JOB!
I'M NOT DOING MY JOB RIGHT NOW!
I'm getting blamed!
Oh god, there's a whole meeting happening right now.
No.
Oh.
So hectic.
Wait, can I...
What?
I told you I crunched the numbers.
What do you mean you crunched the numbers?
What numbers?
It was...
I said it was down to her...
I didn't... I didn't even start the fire!
I was here!
Ella more showed up, dude!
And I was like just next to it!
Oh, that's crazy.
I didn't even start the fire.
I was like, ooh, what is this button to?
I guess she found out, I guess.
This is my first time being a slacker.
Yeah, apparently... Yeah, when you're a slacker, you have a chance for the virus to be on your PC automatically.
So it does suss them out a little bit.
Yeah.
If you're a slacker, you need to get that task where you can spread the virus so you look less sussed.
Pretty much.
That's pretty dumb.
I didn't know that.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
It's a little suss.
Oh, but that means you can plant the virus thing on other people's computer.
But if you get caught with the floppy disk, you're extra, extra sussed.
How is Ella always a slacker?
Yeah, he got it three times in a row.
I just kind of... I don't want to be the slacker.
I don't want to be the slacker.
I don't want to be the slacker either, honestly.
The thing is, anyone asks you what the task is for a normal specialist, I can't name you one.
I don't even know one.
Thanks for being a sub in my chat, Lily Peachy.
Appreciate that a lot.
Who hasn't been manager yet?
Maybe we make the manager.
Yeah, yeah.
Foolish, have you been manager?
I was our very first one.
Lily, Lily.
I believe in you.
Okay, let's give Lily manager.
And then we're missing one person.
Oh, perfect, perfect.
I'm customizing my character.
Hope you're ready, Lily.
It's a lot of responsibility.
It is a lot of responsibility.
We're really counting on you.
Wait, I was...
Lily!
We really are counting on you.
The company will go bankrupt if you don't do a good job, Lily.
Oh, no.
I would love to be your assistant.
Oh, my God.
Slacker again?
Oh, I'm no slacker, baby.
Let's go.
I mean, we can just bug you out, doesn't it?
Hey, I got my job back!
Janet, you did it!
I got my job back, Janet!
Wait, what's that?
What's wrong?
I didn't!
I got my job back!
You vouched for me, right?
Yes, I vouched for you!
I vouched for you!
Oh, my God.
I knew it.
I knew you were in it for the long run.
Thank you so much.
I really appreciate it.
And I got you, too.
I got you, too.
What are you doing?
Tell me what you're doing right now.
Oh, she got my job back!
I got promoted!
Because she's my co-worker.
Yeah, I'm not Janet anymore.
What?
Yeah, and I'm gonna go do another job now.
You're just really quiet.
Okay.
All right, I gotta pick up the trash.
Who's... this is my... I got...
Can anybody throw some trash on the floor?
Wow, that's unexpected.
All right.
I'm gonna... guys, I'm gonna...
I won't tell anyone.
Well, like...
Wait.
First of all...
First of all, I'm a neutral.
Yeah?
And second of all, why is even buying a banana, like, considered a strong thing?
Yeah.
Like, why would there be a vending machine?
Because she's not working.
Why would there be a vending machine?
Yeah, but it's a quick snap.
It's my break time.
Yeah, but we're supposed to work.
We can't have any break.
It's my break hours.
We each have five-minute break time every day.
I'm taking my five minutes.
I got five kids.
She has diabetes.
She needs the extra...
I don't have time for breaks.
She has diabetes.
She needs to get her sugar levels up.
Exactly.
Is that true?
Yes.
I have it.
She has type 2 diabetes.
Which side?
Which side do you have?
Type 2.
What dogey said?
Yeah, type 2.
Are you discriminating against type 2 diabetes?
What's the difference between one and two?
What do you mean?
What's the difference?
What do you mean, what's the difference?
You can't just question that!
That's her medical history!
What's the difference?
Diabetes, that's messed up!
That's messed up!
Ooh, cake!
You can't question somebody's diabetes medical history!
Yeah, that's insensitive of you!
Yeah, clearly you missed out on sensitivity training.
I apologize.
You know what?
That's my bad.
You know, I was just a little mad, really.
I'm just stressed, really.
No, really?
What's going on?
Wait, let me go grab a beer.
I need to take a sip.
What is going on?
I can't move!
No?
I'm a working man!
Yeah, so what's been stressing you out, Dakin?
Honestly, it's just the wife and the kids really like...
Yeah?
I got so much like... they're just really expecting me to come home and be a dad, really.
And I can't, you know?
Yeah, because you're working a 9 to 5.
It's a hard job.
Exactly.
Oh, I don't feel so good.
My head is...
Oh, don't worry.
You drank on the job.
See?
Don't worry.
We all get one.
We all get one 5-minute break.
Yeah, we should go to the meeting.
Yeah, yeah.
We can file a complaint about the long hours.
Just follow my lead.
Manager?
Manager, I have a question.
Yeah, what's up?
Can we have shorter work hours?
We've been doing a lot of overtime lately.
I disagree.
I think we can double our efforts.
No, you can't.
You're being a loser.
Can we kick this guy out?
I'm surprised you're still alive.
I'm always suspicious of alum, but...
I'm always suspicious of brother Noah.
He's always a strange one.
Yeah, right.
I swear you smack me one more time.
Miss Manager?
Yeah?
Can we start a union?
Yeah, do you see that?
No.
This is a non-union workplace.
This is a non-union workplace?
Huh?
What?
Are you talking to me?
Oh, man.
Okay.
I'm trying to listen, honestly.
I'm trying to listen, so I don't know.
I don't know what you're talking about.
I'm trying to listen.
Yeah, sure, man.
I don't think they can hear me.
Yeah, we can hear you.
They can hear me?
Okay.
Hey, do you guys want to start a union?
A union?
Yeah.
Lily said this is a non-union workplace, and that's not fair.
Like, we need reasonable wages and reasonable work hours.
Dak in here was telling me how he can't even see his wife and kids anymore because of the hours.
Yeah, we should start a union.
What if the entire company revolts against us?
Don't wait!
People don't want extra money?
What if we get enough people to...
Yeah, yeah.
Let's make a petition for a union.
And have everybody sign in.
And then we vote Lily off.
Yeah.
Vote Lily out of position.
And then we'll have a union leader on position.
I mean, I feel like I really speak for the people.
Yeah, I think Dak in would be a great union leader.
But we need more people, though.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'll write the documents.
Blah, would you like to join the union?
Yeah, you want to join the union?
Lily said we're not allowed to have a union, and that's ununion-like.
Hey, Jenna, would you like to join?
You want to join our union?
I'm down to join a union, yeah.
I'm all for you.
We want to get a new manager.
Yeah, yeah.
I'm going to write a petition right now, and we all sign in.
We need licenses and unites us together.
We were just talking about work.
Wait, wait, wait.
Oh, of course, we have a bootlicker here.
Get out of here.
Oh, we got them.
Oh, dang.
What are we doing?
Not being bailed?
Dale and Dawson union.
We demand a union.
Oh.
For fair wages and hours.
Dakin is our union, union leader, and he speaks for us, and it was his idea.
Can you sign this?
Down with the tyrannical leader, manager Lily.
There you go.
Put the floppy disk there.
Innocent.
Dumb man.
All right.
There's like two little domes in front of me.
Like five.
It was me on this pooping on company time.
Get back to work.
Okay, somebody else will find this paper.
Wait, somebody lock the door.
Hello?
I'm saying lock the door.
I think it's the meeting?
You might have to fire someone, Lily.
You might have to fire someone.
Oh, you have to fire Lily.
You're fucking lying.
Lily, you're a weirdo.
All right, let's go.
Lily, meeting.
Lily, LM is like in the...
LM is stuck in the copier room.
We keep blocking the doors.
Dude, it's gotta be someone.
Sakuna has the keys.
You can't...
You have to be an experienced veteran.
I have the keys.
I agree.
There's like two people locked in the copier room, Lily.
Something's sniffing about you.
I can't tell what it is.
I'm a little suspicious of Shoto.
I grew out my hair.
He's not here.
Good job, Lily.
Good job.
So people are stuck in the copier room?
Miss Manager, LM is stuck in the copier room.
Maybe we should keep him there.
Everybody do...
No, keep him there.
Yeah, yeah.
We should keep him there.
No union.
I didn't say anything.
It's our first day.
It's our first day on the job.
Okay.
Sit.
Oh, God.
Who started the fire?
Mi-Jong, did you do that?
Huh?
Yes!
I'm sure it started a fire.
Yeah.
Who decided that?
It was Dakin.
Yeah.
Yeah, Dakin started the fire.
Hey, wait, wait.
There's a fire.
Who is locking the doors?
What's that ringing?
How am I getting this?
Guys, God forbid.
Who ever voted Shoto, by the way, you're safe for that.
I was saying Simmons and then Shoto and then you go vote it out.
Why was he?
You got a sticky note on your back.
Yeah, you got a sticky note.
It says loser.
It said loser.
Yeah, it said loser on the back.
Ellum?
I would never do such a thing.
Wait, is there something behind my back?
Yeah, it says loser.
Wait, I'm not a loser.
Yeah, yeah, loser.
Are you calling the manager the loser?
No, I said I'm not.
No, you're the best, honestly.
Oh, thank you, I know.
Timmy, you were making fun of her name.
Yeah.
I don't even know what that means.
That's a lie.
I'll remember that.
I'll remember.
No, no, that's fine.
That's fine.
No, no, no, no.
Wait, you have something on your back.
No, no, no, there's nothing on my back.
No, what are you doing?
Personal space!
I am the manager.
We do not want another sensitivity training.
Wait, what does it say?
Is that what it says?
Are you putting sticky notes on people?
Wait, what does it say?
What does it say?
100% slacker?
Are you a slacker?
Yeah, I think I was a slacker.
All right, Tina.
What have you discovered, Tina?
Oh, hello, Manager Doki.
Yeah.
It seems Nathan here is potentially dropping infected floppy disks.
Infected?
What?
Where's the proof?
Where's the evidence, Tina?
You have to have evidence for this.
It's on your back.
It's drinking too slow.
Wait, what does it say?
I'm drinking.
I'm just a little tipsy.
It says, turn around.
That's it.
It says, I'm a papaga.
Can you take it off?
Thanks.
Who did that?
It's only...
It was you, wasn't it?
Dakkin, was it you?
Wait, it says Tina's a papaga.
It's something on Dakkin's back.
Dakkin, what are you...
Wait, what about my back?
Are you harassing our coworkers, Dakkin?
Wait, this is my back.
Yeah, it says big loser.
Wait, I'm not a big loser.
Big loser?
I'm not a big loser.
I think we might need...
I think we might need a meeting to have some sensitivity training.
No!
I did it!
It's too late!
I was too late!
I was running!
I was...
I couldn't hear the timer!
I think Dakkin sucks.
Wait, what does it say?
What does it say?
I couldn't...
I couldn't get through in time!
I was roleplaying too hard!
I was...
I seceded in the hostile takeover.
The Union was a success...
But I fell.
I tripped and stumbled before the final...
Life!
And it's ahin.
My takeover was so close!
It was a plow, foolish, and a chocko.
A rise and fall.
The rise and fall of Dokibird management.
Alright, let's just wrap this up.
I'm here to haunt the... I'm here to haunt it.
Wait,
who did he... he fired everybody, but...
I can't believe... nobody got the slacker.
That's crazy.
I hate that I got locked in a...
I'm working with a slacker.
I thought you enjoyed your seven minutes of heaven, Shoto.
I hated that.
I hated it.
It was fucking amazing.
Seven minutes of heaven?
No one heard me.
Dude, the timing was just so good.
It was so good.
I actually have no idea who it was.
The moment he realized it was just me and him in the room, he just...
The room?
Wait.
Actually, no, wait.
I knew it was Janet.
Guys, I have no money.
Really?
I'm gonna put some ice in my drink.
You would.
No, but you chose Kena.
You know, he's the best.
I actually like Kuno and Tina.
No, make Sykuno.
Make Sykuno.
So...
Sykuno, are you ready, brother?
I can't yell at him for locking all the doors.
Wait, yeah.
This would be perfect.
I don't have to worry about him.
Yeah.
Oh, yeah.
Actually, that's... yeah.
Please make him manager.
Please.
All right.
We are missing Lily.
And me.
I'm just customizing.
Oh, no.
Me, I'm here.
Let me customize.
Present.
Hey, wait.
I'm coming.
Nice.
You're dying.
I'm here.
I want to do a sound like that, but I'm worried I'm gonna cut my voice.
Your voice is slowly coming back.
You already sound like that, bro.
Do it.
You won't, pussy.
Pussy?
Yeah, pussy.
Oh, shit.
Oh, what the fuck was that?
I think you can do it louder.
Do you want to bark?
Do it.
Do like one bark.
Pathetic.
Only a slice of your former glory.
Oh, hey guys.
I'm back.
Oh, New York.
We're going to New York.
I'm eating apple.
Shoto Ellum.
Ellum.
I have no idea why they say that.
This is your last warning.
Shape up now.
No.
Oh, my God.
I'm a slacker.
Well.
Oh, hello.
Thank you so much.
What?
Why would you do that?
Okay.
Wait a minute.
I got to do my job.
Hello?
Open.
I got to do my job.
Alright.
Do that thing I do.
Thank you so much.
Do what?
What?
A handshake?
Yeah.
The handshake they're doing.
Thank you.
I'll go straight to work.
Dirty boy.
Where is...
Oh, boy.
Where's the manager?
Paper.
Dina, your mic is...
Your mic is on.
Dude, why?
Server outage.
Oh.
Saikuno.
Saikuno, you got to sign something.
Yeah, sure, sure.
Let me...
There you go.
I fixed the server, Mr. Manager.
Very innocent.
Wait.
No, but you think you are, but you aren't.
Assistant, don't you think you have better things to do with your time?
Actually, wait.
I'm waiting for my tasks.
Oh, new tasks right now.
Oh, wife assistance.
Let's see.
Report relay.
Gotta do my work.
I love my work.
I love working so much.
I'm not suspicious.
I'm a witness.
I want to call...
Call my manager.
Where's my manager?
Are you slacking on the job right now?
No.
Shred some papers.
Shred some papers right into a virus, I bet.
Why is my manager not taking my phone call?
I know what you did.
You're working with Slackamina over here.
Who is also your duo, clearly.
Oh, Jesus Christ, man.
My manager's not taking my call.
I can't believe it.
What happened?
Wait, can you see what it says?
I mean, I can.
I'm in the back.
Wait, it says bad manager.
No.
It's on the ground.
Who wrote that?
Oh, yeah.
He really is.
You only did me on write this note about you.
Oh, my freaking God.
But also, Janet has been working in whatever word that means they've been working together.
Janet and Slackamina, I tell you.
Kahoots, I believe.
Thank you.
We've got 30 seconds.
Slackamina.
She must be the Janet of now.
Mia, what's your defense?
My defense is I've only been doing good and Elm has just been following me around, trying to abuse his power.
That is true.
I can confirm this.
He put a stake on Phyllis.
How do we know if Elm wasn't the one that put it on you?
Yeah.
Oh, my God.
Elm might be right.
I'm going to have to do it.
Thank you so much.
Okay.
Wow.
Good job.
Congratulations.
It's so smart.
Wait, how did you get that shirt?
Congratulations on the new role.
It was in the customization.
No way.
I don't think that's workplace appropriate.
Shake my hand.
Great shirt.
I don't know, man.
Wait, Lily.
You have a note on your back.
You got it wrong.
Wait, you have a note on your back.
Yeah, what does it say?
I can't see it.
Bad manager.
Wait, you're a bad manager?
What?
I don't know.
That's crazy.
Wait, I like your shirt.
Yeah, great shirt.
It's a good shirt.
Wait, what does it say?
You have another...
I actually want this shirt in real life.
You should make your own version.
Wait, what does it say in the back?
Oh, nothing.
You have another note on your back, Sykuno.
Again?
Yeah.
It says great manager this time.
Is that right?
Oh, wow.
Yeah.
I feel like we're all sitting here and nobody's working.
This is looking quite slacked off.
We got fired.
It says great manager.
You got fired, so you should agree with me.
Yeah?
Shake your hand.
Shake my hand.
I'm also the assistant manager.
Oh, yeah, but...
That means you're getting paid less.
Because you're...
You're getting paid less.
You're getting paid less doing an assistant manager duty.
I'm sitting here and crying.
It's like basically an unpaid intern.
Oh.
I believe...
Wait, why did he get fired?
I think...
Dude, I swear I saw you.
See?
Great manager.
This is bad.
This is really bad.
Wait, that's a new note.
That's a new note because you had great manager before.
I thought it was him.
And Doki said I'm an unpaid intern or something.
Because she's a janitor.
Do you pay her...
Does that mean you pay her two wages?
Dude, she's getting paid $700,000 a month.
She gets paid $700,000 a month?
That's more than your paycheck.
That's more than yours.
In Zimbabwe dollars.
Is that why?
Oh, you're screwed.
Yo, that's like five dollars.
That's like five American dollars.
Are you serious?
I don't even think it's five American dollars.
I think it's like one American dollars.
Excellent work, honestly.
Honestly, great management.
Great management.
In my country, that's a compliment.
Hey, nice.
You can shake my hand.
That's the highest form of flattery.
We live in New York.
That's true.
He's not doing anything.
What's on your back, Tita?
What's on your back?
Why'd you laugh?
It says...
I know what it says.
Take it off perfectly.
Wait, what does it say?
What does it say?
It's really embarrassing.
I worked really hard to get to the rank that I'm at.
Daily solo drawing.
I don't think I deserve it.
Who would have done such a thing?
Yeah, yeah, I took it off.
Who could have done that?
He's jealous.
Oh, I bet he's even lower ranked than Iron.
He is.
He's genuinely.
He's like, what's lower than Iron?
That's what I'm saying.
Wait, Iron's the lowest?
I'm the only one who does their job and the manager doesn't want to do their job.
We are doomed.
I have problems with Elem.
I don't think I've seen him do anything.
I think everybody has problems.
Even if he is supposed to be a hard worker, he never will work.
That's what I know about him.
I mean, he got you fired.
Wait, you can stick it on your butt?
You have it sticking out on your ass!
Yeah, this is not good.
Everyone just keeps making fun of me.
Why?
Who made fun of you?
Did you make fun of him?
No.
You made fun of me.
Why?
I hit me, Hun.
I trusted you.
I gotta take a dump.
We have three terminations and three slappers left.
You're gonna lose your job.
I'm gonna lose my job.
No matter what, we take Elem out.
What?
We have to get the next three correct or it's all over.
The next three will go.
You definitely won.
No, I'm innocent.
I really do need you to fix my computer so I can progress.
We're busy.
We're busy right now.
We're having a manager's meeting right now.
I'll come check it later.
Can I listen in?
Can I shadow you guys?
No, no, it can't be.
Oh, wait, why not?
Well, I guess she did...
I guess she does do her work.
We've gotta vote someone out.
And I have no clue who it is.
I think it's probably not Lily.
I mean, it's just...
What if it's Elem again?
I have no clue.
What if for one time in this life it's actually him?
He's been a lot actually.
Oh, I can't ever tell because he's in every game.
Also, is everyone just sitting here?
Wait, what's going on?
There's no meeting.
We're getting ready.
We just love working here.
We just love your company.
I think you forget about what everyone else thinks and you listen to what your brain tells you.
Listen to your heart.
Own hard work.
We all know who it is, right guys?
We all know who it is.
You know who it is.
Oh, I don't know.
I've been trying to post a TikTok.
So are you sitting here?
I'm a specialist.
I'm a specialist too.
Tina, who is it?
I just want you guys to know that Blau was in the lunchroom lighting it up listening to music while you were on it.
Blau, is that true?
I believe that.
It must be.
Blau is also sipping coffee with him.
I hear what you're saying, guys.
I hear what you're saying.
I know it's you.
Oh my god.
Guys, I've been...
Can you fire Elm for me?
Can you fire Elm?
Just fire Elm.
Take the shot.
Take it.
Get out of here.
This is like the only slacker shot you get right.
Get him out.
Just get him out.
Just get this guy out.
Final meeting.
No, you have one more.
You have like two more meetings.
Tell us why it isn't you.
Because I know damn well it's this guy right here with the orange beard.
Guys, let's turn this on its head.
That's workplace harassment.
It's foolish.
It was foolish.
I was the next one to fire Elm.
Wait.
Prejudice works?
We're allowed to be prejudiced against other people because of their hair color?
No.
You were wrong.
That makes so much sense.
Wait.
Are we allowed to judge people with their hair color?
Let me ask her some hard hitting questions.
Tina, tell me why isn't you your big slacker?
What are you talking about?
You're the one that's been running around putting...
You've been putting sticky notes on everybody's backs.
And she pooped!
She pooped her pants!
You pooped your pants!
It didn't go on the back of your thing!
Is this the back of your thing?
She blamed Blau and he was actually a hard worker?
Is this your poop behind your back?
I think Ellum's right.
He got the first one right.
Get her out, brother.
Get her out.
No, it's what it says behind your back.
No way.
Yeah, it says, I pooped my pants.
Dang it.
Shit.
Janet!
What's Janet?
Well.
I wish you big nod.
I knew it was you.
I can't believe it was Janet all along.
It was me all along.
I don't know why I got voted.
There was no way I could have known.
I knew.
I knew it was you.
Just like you knew it was Tina?
Shut your ass up.
That was a good one, honestly.
Thank you for the games.
Bye.
Oh, thank you for the games.
Yeah, that was my LG as well.
Oh.
It would.
I remember when you were cool.
Wait, damn.
Damn.
Yo, yo, holy shit.
Next time I see you, next time I see you, it's on site.
Yeah.
Oh, it's on.
It's on site.
Oh, yeah.
It's going to get messy.
Wait, why did you say it like that?
Wait, why messy?
Like, what's happening?
It's going to...
Why would it be messy?
Why does it really want to be for?
Sweaty, I don't know.
Lots of liquids.
Just tangled up.
Just getting in.
Yeah.
Just taking care of business.
Upwards, downwards.
Seven minutes of heaven.
Downwards.
Whoa.
Perpetual.
Okay.
I'm kind of jealous, honestly.
No, trust me.
You don't want me to buy this.
GGs.
Good games, everybody.
Good games.
Yeah, I guess that's just how it ends.
That's just...
Wait, are the rest of us still playing?
Are we still playing this or are we gaming elsewhere?
Wait, who left?
Who left?
Well, okay.
Right now...
I think...
I mean, we're still nine people, right?
Nine of us.
Or we could try to do like...
Oh, we're close to an in-house right now.
In-house?
Oh.
Valor?
In-house?
I can play one, maybe.
You can play two.
You can play three.
Guys, I don't...
We don't even have ten.
Oh.
What time is it?
It's only 4 p.m.
Yeah, exactly.
There's so much time.
What do you do?
What do they mean by in-house?
No, no.
It's only four p.m.
Guys.
Yeah.
It's only four p.m.
Are they trying to get me to play Valorant?
Yeah.
I mean...
You're not trying to play some horror game now, are you?
Listen, listen, listen.
The game is only an hour long and I can just play it after the in-house.
No.
You're good for two.
Exactly.
Wait, what?
You're good for two.
I'll bring it to like six o'clock or something and then boom.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
And then just one hour of...
It's way better at night anyway.
You can't play a horror game unless it's nighttime.
Everyone log on, log on.
It's too bright outside anyways.
Okay.
Too bright.
That's too bright.
It's not as good when it's bright outside.
It would ruin the immersion.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
There's too light in here.
It's too bright.
My heart is too bright.
All right.
Guys, is this a Valorant thing?
I haven't played in a while though.
It's okay.
Yeah, it's okay.
That's okay, man.
It's okay.
That's what they all say.
That's fine.
Elm has an hyzer.
It's okay.
I only request one thing.
I don't want to be on Foolish's team.
Oh.
You're still trying to outfrag him?
No.
I just like playing against him.
Let it rest.
Okay.
Am I allowed to play Chamberlain?
Nine to five and then you go home to play some Valorant.
Oh my god.
That's good.
Right?
You guys get to play.
Guys, I don't play Valorant.
Foolish, right?
Not that I don't like you, Foolish.
I love Valorant.
I love Vi's.
Yeah.
Wait.
You got a new champ?
Oh, yeah.
I'm a Vi's main now.
Yeah.
I'm into Viber.
I may go with Viber now.
I don't know.
I don't know what to say.
I don't know how to interject.
How do I get out of this?
I don't know how to get out of it.
Vi's.
Yeah.
Maybe we can find somebody early.
It's so early in the day.
Yeah.
Guys.
I don't know how to play Valorant.
Is this Valorant?
Is this a Valorant thing?
Oh, wow.
But you can learn now and it's going to be awesome.
Yeah.
I'm going to be honest.
If you've never played Valorant, you're going to get hard farmed.
But I mean, I ain't going to lie to you, you know, like...
Wait.
Then where's the fun?
How come somebody said it's going to be fun?
It's the one in the farming?
It'll be fun.
I mean, listen.
It's going to be really fun if you like getting destroyed.
What's up?
Hey.
I don't know.
It's like a thing, you know.
Oh.
I just can't quite tell what that angle would be.
Yeah, me neither.
Well, I was trying to tell her like...
Well...
No.
Never mind.
Oh.
I don't know.
Okay.
I flamed LM enough today.
How do I get out of that?
How is it going to fit into that exactly?
It's where it's going to get up.
All right.
So...
Do you know what peer pressure feels like?
I will refrain LM, you are late.
This is peer pressure?
I will purposely antagonize you until you let it out.
That is crazy!
Do we hear this?
You can't just say all that and not do it.
Do we hear him?
Oh my freaking god.
I feel like you gotta do it now.
Vote him out!
No, cause then he's just gonna spam actually die.
Die in real life.
Die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die.
He's spamming it in the...
It's crazy.
That's insane.
That's crazy!
Wait, what started this?
He's crazy.
Get on the bully.
Dude, are you kidding me?
Do you see what he's typing to me?
Actually, wait, that's kinda true.
I would never do such a thing.
It's all a lie.
It's all photoshopped.
Wait, so do we have a tenth?
Dang it.
Certainly there are a few more.
I messaged like three or four.
You say you got one.
She's always down.
She's always down, but she's doing something right now.
Oh, you would.
You would.
Okay, I'm copy and pasting.
I'm copy and pasting.
Boom, we're gonna be good for one right here.
The ad here always works.
Oh my god, I don't know.
It's just one game.
Wait, do we only need one?
Wait, Doki, are you playing?
Doki, do we have an account?
Yeah, I have an account, but I don't get farmed.
I don't know.
Just be on full esteem.
Doki, go mid.
Go mid with me every single time, okay?
Are you just gonna bait me?
Just one rule, don't listen to LM.
Don't listen to him, don't follow him.
I'll do one game.
Let's get away from it.
You might just have the time of your life.
It might be good for two.
Two games, Doki, come on.
Yeah, but then you're gonna be like, three games.
Come on, Doki, three games.
That never happens.
No, no, two is a healthy amount.
You can't just do one.
Guys, I have to install Valorant.
You might have to restart your computer.
I don't know if you want to do that.
Oh, that's too bad, guys.
You guys might need to find two.
It's good that we figured this out now, though.
No, yeah, yeah.
Next time, you can get me in next time.
Yeah, yeah, when I have it installed.
Yeah, gg's, guys.
Gg's.
Have a good one.
Bye, Doki.
I'm still here already.
I'm still here.
Bye, guys.
Bye.
I say it because I didn't install.
I didn't install Valorant.
Thank God.
I was so nervous.
I was like, guys, I don't play Valorant.
But you guys play Valorant all the time.
I was nervous because I don't play the game.
So I was just like, oh my gosh.
I'm so nervous.
I'm going to get farmed.
I get farmed so hard.
Maybe next time.
Maybe next time if I'm more warmed up.
If I'm more like, you know, warmed up for it.
Wow.
I just experienced peer pressure.
Again.
Because usually Gumi is the one that peer pressures me in Valorant.
But I experienced group peer pressure today.
Drez, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
That was a close one.
The classic, I have to install it.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I hope you guys had a lot of fun.
It was a lot of fun playing with a group of people.
Like I said, it was my It was like my first time playing with a lot of these people.
I hope that I didn't spill too much spaghetti today.
And like people enjoyed watching me on other people's stream.
I hope you guys enjoyed the stream with all the flesh tubers today.
It was pretty fun.
I liked the roleplay aspect of the game in general.
Because we were pretending to work at the office.
And all my knowledge about working in the office was just watching the office.
And I hope you guys had a lot of fun watching.
It was a lot of fun playing.
And as always, everybody stay hydrated.
Posture check.
Get up and move around to get that blood flowing.
And if you stayed up for me, head to bed.
Because you deserve it.
Oh yeah, by the way, before I see you guys next time, the sponsor stream for tomorrow is going to be moved to Friday.
So tomorrow's stream is just going to be a member stream.
The sponsor stream is I just signed the I just finalized all the details for it.
So the reason why it was a special stream is because nothing was finalized yet.
But it got finalized this morning.
And it is a free to play game called Fast Penguin.
I did tell you guys I'm taking a lot more sponsors the oncoming week.
Because I have a lot of bills to pay.
So I hope you guys are okay with the fact that I'm doing a lot of sponsors this oncoming week.
So it's actually a free to play Battle Royale racing game.
So I'll be doing that on Friday.
And yeah, so that's really all the updates for today.
I know I wrote update stuff usually on my server.
I don't think I have any other updates.
There was something I wanted to give you guys a story time about, but I forgot what the story was.
I already forgot the story.
I was like, oh my god, I can't wait to tell chat about the story.
Oh wait, let me tell you guys about the story.
Basically I had the most fucking awkward encounter yesterday when I went to grab food downstairs at the lobby.
I went downstairs at the lobby and then there was like a group of like a group of I guess like an Asian family downstairs and then like you know, there was like mom, a grandma, a grandpa like teenagers or young adults or whatever.
And then one of the young adults approached me and was like, hey, do you remember me?
And I was so taken aback because I was like, why are you approaching me?
I was just like, I'm like, sorry?
And then he was like, are you a rent owner?
Are you a renter owner?
And I was like, rent.
And then he like walked back to the table and I was like, what?
I was just like, why the fuck did you approach me?
Like, who are you?
He's like, do you, hey, remember me?
I'm like, obviously not.
That was so awkward.
I'm like, I'm just trying to, bro.
I'm just trying.
I don't know who you are.
Anyway guys, that was my story.
Also, yesterday was so, okay, I was walking, I was walking dad and then when I was walking him, I was over, there was a conversation happening behind me while I was like, walking him and then I heard these two guys, they were like, yeah, they're like,
one of them, the conversation perked my interest because what I heard was one of them was like, it's so hard to watch movies without shrooms these days.
And I'm just like, what the?
And then the other guy, the other guy was like, oh, you should watch Super Mario.
It's so good with shrooms.
And I'm like,
I was just like, what?
I was just like, what the fuck is, what is this conversation?
Anyway, it like, stuck with me because I was like, what the fuck?
Anyway, that all awkward encounter lives rent free in my head right now.
Like, it's been living rent free in my head because I'm like, am I supposed to recognize him?
Like, imagine if people just do that to fuck with people because now, like, they live rent free.
It lives rent free because I'm like, am I supposed to recognize this man?
I swear, honestly, that's like, such an evil thing to do.
You just go up to random people and be like, hey, do you remember me?
And then just walk away afterwards.
Like, it's just like, that just lives rent free.
I think it lives rent free in my head.
Like, who are you?
Also, Josh, thank you so much for the Akasupa.
Thank you, thank you.
Need help with your bills?
Thank you for the Akasupa.
Thank you, thank you.
It's more so of like, the lawyers and like, the finance people because I had to go to a lot of meetings with lawyers and stuff recently regarding my new company.
So, I was like, regarding like, being the new director of a company.
So, I'm just taking in like, more sponsors just to like, make up for the lawyer fees from the advising and like, trademark and stuff like that.
It was just a it was just, you know, obviously lawyers are expensive.
But yes, thank you for the Akasupa.
I really appreciate it.
Thank you so much.
Anyway, guys, like I said, as always everybody, stay hydrated, posture check, get up and move around to get that blood flowing.
And if you stay up for me, head to bed, cause you deserve it!
I'll see you guys next time everybody!
Bye guys!
Bye!